cake wait so was trinken ja so bin ich nicht so früh wie letzte woche letzte
woche war ich ja 8 uhr 30 oder so irgendwie in dem dreh schon da aber da
war es ja auch erst gerade nach der zeitumstellung zeitumstellung ist so ein
ding sollten wir das nicht eigentlich also wollen sie das nicht eigentlich
abschaffen mit der zeitumstellung ja es gab doch irgendwie mal so eine
umfrage vor vier jahren oder so wohl wo die leute sie gesagt haben ja mach weg
dann konnten sie sich nicht einigen auf was aber ich meine nur weil man sich
nicht auf irgendwas einigen kann heißt ja nicht dass man es jetzt einfach sein
lässt da muss man halt gucken dass man sich auf irgendwas einigt ja das ist ein
aufgeblasenes keine ahnung bürokratisches teil also da keine ahnung
kannst nichts von erwarten
leute in einer woche ist battlefield raus nicht mal ganz eine woche am 12 das
ist freitag nächste woche nächste woche freitag so und ich kann euch sagen was
ich video technisch machen werde also am montag oder vielleicht heute noch muss
ich mal gucken ich gehe mal eher vom montag aus montag kommt ein video
allerdings nicht zu battlefield sondern story time
manche im stream werden vielleicht sagen gesagt story weil ich das schon mal
erzählt habe aber mal gucken und da muss ich dann ein bisschen hetzen das erlaubt
machen drin und nächste woche irgendwann wahrscheinlich ein tag vor
release ich habe weil leider war das alles alles alles nicht so hingehauen
ich habe ein paar cutter gesucht die mir aus meinen battlefield livestreams so
irgendwie so einen keine ahnung paar minuten highlight oder was auch immer
wie viel highlight video schneiden aus diesen drei battlefield beta livestreams
ich gemacht habe der erste hat gesagt er macht und auf einmal hat er es dann
nicht mehr gemacht will ich jetzt nichts erzählen so weiter weil vielleicht will
er es nicht haben wir uns einen zweiten gesucht da hat er gesagt er braucht eine
woche für das ist heute fertig mal gucken also es war grausam es ist
leider ein bisschen spät ich wollte es schon vor ein paar wochen hochladen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich lade es jetzt einfach irgendwie 212 tage vor
release hoch ist kriegt dann zwar nicht so viele views aber dann ist das video
nicht umsonst und vielleicht stimmt die leute ein bisschen auf battlefield ein
muss man mal gucken alles klar so schauen wir mal was war
man dann jetzt stonks gab es irgendwelche spannenden news
diese woche
die ich verpasst habe facebook benennt sich oben aber das wird ja schon ein
bisschen her gab es irgendwas spannendes was mal überlegen was spannendes stehen
gab es irgendwas spannendes als weiterer einsatz von corona war warum nicht warum
nicht juckt mich nicht erste messergebnisse zu windows 11 ja mal gucken das habe ich
gelesen das fand ich witzig kopierschutz hat problem mit den neuen cpus
weil die cpu nicht so gut funktioniert die cpu nicht so gut funktioniert die cpu
ist wahrscheinlich erkennt auf welcher plattform es läuft ein crash also genau
das was kopierschutz nicht machen sollte so all die talk gab es auch nichts
sonderlich spannendes ja also es war diese woche tatsächlich relativ wenig
spannendes nix irgendwie vielleicht ja ja ja wahrscheinlich gucken niemand kauft
mehr intel das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht
ja ich dass die facilität trotzdem auch ich habe gerade im grösseren bereich also im enterprise
bereich siehst du immer noch kaum amd systeme jetzt mal frage an euch wer auch hier so auf
die it kommt wie ist der anteil bei euch im rechenzentrum intel zu minded also bei uns
ist es ungefähr so und 99 zu 1 bei dem auch ich sag dieses 1 auch nur dabei weil ich mir
gar nicht sicher bin ob wir überhaupt ab dieses thema haben könnte schon sein könnte schon sein
99 zu 1, anstatt
zu 100%. Ja,
Firmen-Notebook ist auch Intel, genau.
Also gerade im Enterprise-Bereich.
Äh, gut,
ja, bei Headstar haben die, ich weiß,
aber, gut,
das, ich sag mal, das meine ich jetzt damit nicht.
Also,
es mag
vielleicht im Desktop-Bereich sein, dass Intel
weniger verkauft wird, wobei ich glaube,
dass immer noch viele,
so der richtig Hardcore-Gamer, die quasi
sagen, ich will jedes letzte FPS auch
egal koste, was es wolle, immer noch Intel kaufen.
Aber,
das Gute ist,
bei den aktuellen CPUs,
also, das Gute bei den aktuellen
CPUs ist ja, dass Intel
jetzt auch anfängt, es gab ja jetzt erst
letztens einen Intel,
was, 1200, der da, ne?
Das ist, glaube ich, der neue, kann das sein?
Genau, und da habe ich mal
ein bisschen Benchmarks geguckt,
der ist schon,
weil das sieht man hier wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo
drin, eine Benchmark, der ist schon
ein bisschen,
schneller als der, als der Ryzen,
hier, verbraucht aber halt auch
richtig viel Strom, aber,
was man daran sieht ist, eine
Sache, die wir wirklich AMD zu verdanken
haben, dass wir
jetzt endlich angekommen sind auf dem Desktop
bei 12 und 16 Kerne. Ich weiß gar nicht,
was hat denn der, wie viele Kerne hat der? Ich glaube, der hat
2x8 oder so, ne?
Hier, 2x8, genau.
Die haben 16 Kerne,
ein, ein, äh, 8 Superschnelle
und 8, äh, irgendwie
Low Power oder sowas.
Und das wäre jetzt, also, das haben wir
exklusiv, einzig und allein
AMD zu verdanken,
dass wir auf dem Desktop
jetzt quasi Mainstream-mäßig
8, 12 und 16 Kerne haben.
Hätte Intel noch das Sagen
gehabt, die nächsten
irgendwie 5, 6 Jahre
jetzt, also hier, die letzten 5, 6
Jahre und jetzt immer noch,
hätten wir im High-End-Segment
auf dem Desktop 8 Kerne und
ansonsten 4 und 6.
Eventuell, eventuell
mal 10 oder so,
wenn das, äh, super krass, äh,
äh, teuer wäre.
Aber wir hätten garantiert nie
im Leben Mainstream-mäßig
8, 12 und 16 Kerne ohne AMD.
Da bin ich mir relativ
sicher, weil wenn man sich anguckt,
dass Intel über Jahre hinweg
eigentlich nie die Chorzahl geändert
hat, ähm, es gab ja im Prinzip
immer 4 und dann mal ab dem
8700,
ähm, ist dann so im High-End-Segment,
auch, äh, 6 Kerne
aufgekommen. Wir wären nie im Leben
von 6 Kernen auf
16 Kerne raufgegangen,
so im normalen, sagen wir mal, so im normalen
Preissegment, also halbwegs normalen Preissegment
für den Desktop, auch wenn das Zeug hier
schweineteuer ist, äh, also,
sich leistbaren Preissegment
auf dem Desktop ohne AMD
wären wir einfach nicht gewesen.
Da bin ich mir sehr sicher.
Und das haben wir tatsächlich AMD zu verdanken,
unabhängig davon, ob AMD jetzt noch die nächsten Jahre
großartig hier oben mit dabei sein wird,
wobei ich mir durchaus vorstellen könnte,
wenn der
Ryzen 3 ist es jetzt,
ne, also wenn quasi Ryzen 4,
wann kommt denn eigentlich Ryzen 4?
Was ist denn das dann?
Ryzen 6690
oder so?
Nächsten Ryzen CPUs
Release, wann kommt denn das? Haben die eigentlich schon irgendwas gesagt?
Ryzen
alle CPUs
2022, ja, erzähl.
Ah, gut, mal schauen.
Also sobald da das nächste
kommt, ist wahrscheinlich AMD wieder vorne.
Zumal Intel ja es aktuell auch
nicht so richtig schafft. Also das Ding ist zwar
schnell, wenn ich hier diesen Test richtig gelesen
habe, ist das Ding ja schnell, aber
wird wohl ziemlich warm und verbraucht
wohl ziemlich viel Strom. Kann man
schauen. Ja,
das in dem Fall wohl auf jeden Fall.
Weiß nicht, was das Ding kostet.
Aber Intel hat auch CPUs,
die tatsächlich ganz günstig sind
für das, was sie bringen.
Intel muss das ja ein bisschen
über den Preis machen in letzter Zeit.
Ja, Preis steht
nicht dabei.
Was kosten so welche hier?
Was kosten so einer?
Ja.
Ach ja, Schnapper.
Naja, muss man aber mal sagen,
ein Ryzen 5950
ist jetzt auch nicht so viel.
So viel billiger.
Ja, kostet sogar mehr.
Also.
Ja.
Sofern ist das
dann gar nicht mal übel.
Aber das Ding muss wohl ziemlich
großes Stromverbrauch haben.
Das ist natürlich High-End-Segment.
Also sprich, wenn man mal in den
unten drunter guckt, ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
wieder das Ganze anders verteilt.
Warum ist ARM auf dem Desktop eigentlich?
Naja, bei Apple, ich wollte gerade sagen, bei Apple schon.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es besser ist
als x86, nur weil Apple das macht.
Ja, man darf nicht vergessen,
was da alles dranhängt. Die meiste Software
gibt es halt nur für x86. Bei Apple
ist es halt so,
Apple kann das machen und entweder
ziehst du als Softwareentwickler nach,
zumal die ja auch nicht umsonst so ihre
Emulationen dabei haben, entweder
ziehst du als Softwareentwickler nach oder bist
dead. Apple kann halt einfach
machen, was sie wollen.
Nachdem eines der größten
Vorteile von x86 in
Verbindung mit Windows ja nun mal ist,
dass alles läuft, auch
Dinger, die 100 Jahre alt
sind, wäre das glaube ich eine blöde
Idee.
So.
Also.
Ich wollte euch mal ein Video zeigen.
Habe ich richtig gut gemacht.
Ja.
Weiß nicht, ob das einer schon gesehen hat,
aber das ist wahrscheinlich, weil das ist fast
neun Millionen Aufrufe.
Aber ich finde das ultra nice gemacht.
Das ist die Jurassic, diese T-Rex Szene aus
Jurassic Park mit der Katz.
Richtig, richtig Poggers gemacht.
Moment, ich muss, ich muss lauter machen.
Zack.
Da weißt du erst mal, wie sich eine Maus fühlt.
Äh.
Es ist ein Fisch und es basiert auf der Bewegung.
MonkaS.
Ich finde es echt, du hast das echt gut gemacht.
Aber da kannst du dir erst mal, da kannst du dir erst mal vorstellen, wie sich irgendeine
Maus fühlt.
Stell dir mal vor, du guckst da raus und vor dir steht so eine Katze und klotzt dich
an.
Also ich glaube, die fühlen sich, also man kann, also man kann, also wer den Film gesehen
hat, ne, du hast ja da schon, ist ja nicht so, also man konnte sich ja doch ganz gut
hereinversetzen, wie das ist, wenn ich jetzt gerade so irgendein Fleisch fresse.
Und dann kommt da so ein riesiger, so ein riesiger, so ein riesiger, so ein riesiger
Dinosaurier, der sich da so einen fressender Dinosaurier anguckt.
Und so ungefähr muss das für die Katz aus.
Oh, es gibt neue Battlefield Fans.
Poggers.
Also wir müssen jetzt gucken.
Massive.
Es gibt neue Battlefield Fans.
Huge.
The engineer needs ammo, what are you guys doing over here?
Oh no, look who I met.
Ist das neu?
Hä?
Das ist ein Reupload.
Huge.
Ah, wir gucken den trotzdem.
Der ist, glaube ich, ganz guter.
This is the administrator.
What's up?
This is server.
Okay, great.
He's on our team.
Okay.
What the hell is in your hand?
Is that there a shotgun?
That's a shotgun.
Oh, you can't have any shotguns in here.
Talking about I can't have a shotgun.
You brought a shotgun.
You're not allowed to have a shotgun in here.
Well, you need to say that.
I didn't know you couldn't have them.
Okay, fine.
I'll swap them out when I die next.
How about that?
Okay, sounds good.
You're banned.
Whoa, hey, hey.
Whoa, hey.
We're the...
Es gibt halt wirklich so Server.
Gut, in Battlefield 3 nicht mehr.
Da gibt es noch fünf Server oder so, die aktiv sind, wenn man da Leute bannt, ist halt
kannst du das Spiel aninstallen.
Oh, we just brought a shotgun into the server.
Okay, so?
You can't do that.
Oh, okay.
I didn't know that was...
Is this another one of your buddies?
Yeah, this is the administrator.
He owns this place.
Own it.
He's on our team.
Well, great.
Can we go out there and...
Guys, guys.
Guys, I got a chopper on me.
Somebody help.
Who the hell is that?
Are you camping?
No, no.
I'm being attacked by a chopper.
You're just sitting there in that building.
Are you camping?
No, no.
I'm hiding in a building so I don't get shot by a chopper.
Oh, wait.
No, that's my friend.
He's our sniper.
Oh, he's your friend?
Yeah.
What's the chopper's guy's name?
What's his name?
I don't know.
Freeze something?
Freeze.
I read...
Banned.
Thank you.
Wow.
Was that awesome?
No, it wasn't.
He just banned that guy.
Yeah, but the guy was playing fair.
Okay.
He had a chopper.
I'm not fair.
Because the chopper was offered in the game.
If it's in the game, it's...
I don't like this guy's storytelling.
You do have bad storytelling.
I'm not telling a goddamn story.
I don't know where you guys are pulling that.
I'm getting very bored of this guy.
I'm gonna ban him.
Yeah.
If you're gonna be a storyteller, you need to up your game a little bit.
I'm not trying to tell a fucking story.
Well, get another middle.
I don't like his middle.
Yeah.
The beginning was okay.
Climax.
Solution.
Right.
What's Act 3 gonna be like?
Okay, okay.
Well, here's my solution.
Banned.
My solution is you shouldn't ban people.
Oh, fuck.
Get down.
Oh, shit.
We're taking fire.
Get down.
Okay, look, guys.
I'm gonna try to flake these guys.
You guys try to attack from the front.
Okay?
Try to attack from the front and run around.
Who cares?
Everyone just relax.
Banned.
Shit is easy.
Did you see that?
This game is easy.
That's not even fun.
And that's not even fair for those guys.
Dude, we're gonna totally win this match.
Yeah, we're gonna win.
Because you're basically cheating.
As an administrator, you're banning people.
Do you get it?
Yeah, we're gonna win.
Because you're basically cheating.
As an administrator, you're banning people.
Just because they're better than you.
That's not fun.
That's not sporty.
That's just...
It's basically cheating.
You can't do that.
Oh, the last time I checked my credit card, I could do whatever the fuck I want.
Bam!
Come back tomorrow for repair tools only.
Repair tools only.
Es gibt halt wirklich so Leute.
Und nicht zu wenige.
Nicht zu wenige.
Wisst ihr, wo das ganz schlimm war?
Bei Venice Unleashed.
So die, die zwei, drei Wochen, wo das ganz schlimm war.
Das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war,
das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war, das war,
das war, das war, das war, das war, das war.
Die hatten halt keine offiziellen Server und da war es sogar so, dass du...
Dass der Server auch damit gecheatet hat.
Alter!
Das war echter Wahnsinn.
Also, nee.
Seriously, was war das für ein Arsch?
Ach, guck mal.
hier hatte ich noch einen auf, aber noch müssen wir nicht gucken.
Tja, Alter, was ist denn mit
YouTube los? YouTube empfiehlt uns ja nur noch Battlefield.
Ich meine, ich weiß, es kommt gleich raus, aber man muss
es jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Twitch-Mason, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich würde sagen,
wir lassen uns jetzt erstmal eine Runde
von
Level Cap
G-Baden. Wir lassen uns
erstmal eine Runde von Level Cap G-Baden
und mal gucken,
was er erzählt. Ich meine,
er wird im Endeffekt
sich darüber auslassen,
dass, okay,
Overwatch und, ich weiß jetzt schon, was kommt,
Overwatch und Diablo 4
wurden delayed. Das ist ja
bekannt jetzt
mittlerweile. Und ich frage mich,
was Everything You Need To Know, ich meine, das Ganze
kommt am 12. raus. Wir können
jetzt quasi ab, ich glaube, Xbox
kann schon preloaden. Ich glaube, Xbox kann
ab heute preloaden, wenn ich nicht ganz
falsch liege. Und PC kann
ab 10. preloaden.
Und ansonsten, ja, was muss man
wissen? Ja, eigentlich
eigentlich nix.
Wenn man ehrlich ist.
Was soll man wissen müssen?
Man kann ab 12. spielen.
Außer, also man kann
spielen, außer man hat diese ganz ultra low
Edition. Dann kann man, glaube ich, erst ab 16.
oder so spielen. So, gucken wir mal.
Lassen wir uns G-Baden.
Moin, Level Cap.
Ach,
schade.
Ach, schade.
Stimmt, ein Vanguard Review, das hatte ich doch hier auch
offen.
Ja, das müssen wir uns noch angucken.
Da bin ich mal gespannt. Ich hab mich null informiert.
Absolut null. Ich kauf mir das auch nicht.
Warum lassen wir uns
jede Woche von Level Cap neu G-Baden?
Ist doch nice, sich G-Baden zu lassen.
Ähm.
Ja,
also Vanguard kauf ich mir nicht. Das ging voll an mir
vorbei. Ich seh's auch nicht ein. Ich würde das eh nur
bis zum Battlefield Release spielen wahrscheinlich.
Und außerdem kommt dann SBMM.
Oh Leute, ich sag euch jetzt mal was. Ich hab's ja schon
predicted. Äh,
vor Battlefield 2042 Release
und
quasi zur Beta nochmal,
als da kein Serverbrowser
drin war.
Ich könnte wetten,
es kommt in irgendeiner
Art und Weise
limitierter oder nicht vorhandenes
Serverbrowser und
Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch.
Weil dann ist das Game instant dead für mich.
Da werde ich's nicht spielen.
Ich, ich, ich, ich, irgendwie hab ich so
im Gefühl, dass was in dieser Richtung passiert.
Aber hoffen wir mal das
Beste.
Hey Leute, Level Cap hier.
In dieser Woche haben wir alle
Battlefield 2042 Launch-Infos,
Call of Duty Vanguard-Reviews,
große Game-Delays rocken die Industrie
und viel mehr.
Battlefield 2042
startet offiziell in weniger als einer Woche
für die Kostüm- und E-A-Play-
und Xbox-Game-Pass-Subscriber.
Es wird sicherlich ein
Monumental-Launch für die Franchise
und...
Monumental-Launch, alles klar.
...while there's still a lot of unknowns like
how we'll balance 2042...
Ich glaube, der Launch wird erstmal wie bei fast
jedem Battlefield.
Wer findet die meisten Bugs innerhalb der ersten
24 Stunden?
...who will be, whether or not the community will
embrace or reject specialists,
which mode will be the most popular
and so on and so forth.
We do have plenty of official details
to cover. Firstly, preload times
were announced...
Nee, Xbox kann schon preloaden.
...today it's 7 o'clock UTC.
PC and PlayStation players can start
preloading on the 10th.
The early access period begins on the 12th
for Golden Ultimate Edition preorders.
You'll also get a 10-hour trial
Ich mein, guckt euch mal die anderen Maps an.
Wenn man sich diese Maps anschaut,
da ist halt auch nix.
Außer irgendwo
ab und zu mal ein bisschen was.
Können wir die neuen
geleakten Gameplays schauen?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht, ob man das schauen kann.
Also, wenn das auf irgendwelchen
großen, bekannten Channels ist,
dann schon. Wenn es jetzt irgendwelche
so Ein-Video-Channels sind,
die sich das nur für die Leaks angemacht haben,
dann nicht.
Dann weiß ich nicht, wie tos das ist.
Die Maps sehen halt auch alle schon
wieder so leer und so im Prinzip
wie Orbital, nur
mit einem anderen Setting halt aus.
Ich bin da echt kein Freund
von gewesen.
Orbital war ja im Prinzip
einfach so,
so eine 0815-Battle-Royale-Map
ohne die typischen Battlefield-Routen,
die du so hattest. Du hattest zwar
diesen Tunnel unten drunter, da konntest du
aber nicht durchlaufen. Ansonsten, du hattest
im Prinzip nur offenes Feld
überall und keine sinnvollen
Routen über die Map.
Du hattest einfach offenes Feld.
Du kannst sagen, du hast nahezu unendlich viele Routen, aber das bringt
dir ja nix, wenn alles offenes Feld ist.
Also.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Ich hab da immer noch so meine Bedenken.
Huge Aim.
Bam!
Eine Auto-Shotgun?
War das,
haben wir das richtig? War das eine Auto-Shotgun?
Da wird wieder geflammt.
They're absolutely massive, based on
what DICE has described and also
based on the visuals.
that we've seen from the teasers.
The second mode is Portal.
This combines classic maps, weapons,
gadgets and classes from 1942
Bad Company to Battlefield 3
with all of the modern
2042 vehicles and weapons
and gadgets and maps
in one massive sandbox experience.
Portal offers deep
server customization. We recently
did a video... Hast du den Reddit-User gesehen,
der schon spielen kann? Er hat keine...
Ich hab
da irgendeinen News-Artikel drüber gelesen,
wo die Leute in Zweifel dran hatten,
dass das legit ist.
Der hat das ja angeblich...
Ist das der, der angeblich preloaded hat
und er konnte schon spielen?
...Portals-Mode-Options.
So be sure to watch that video for more info.
Finally, there's Hazard Zone.
This is an extraction survival experience
where you team up in a four-man squad
in 32 player matches.
The objective is to collect...
Schick mal bitte einen Link,
das können wir uns angucken.
...and extract them from the map
before a storm shuts down air support.
We don't really know too much about how this game
is actually going to play.
...layout, aside from...
Das ist auch sowas.
Da hab ich, ehrlich gesagt,
ein bisschen Bedenken.
Ähm, die Sache ist nämlich die,
man hat bei fast jedem Battlefield
im Vorfeld
irgendwas...
Also du wusstest quasi bei jedem Battlefield
mehr als bei dem hier.
Also bei dem...
Was wissen wir zu dem Spiel?
Wir wissen zwar so die Rahmenbedingungen,
was weiß ich, wie viele Maps,
wir kennen ein paar Specialists,
wir kennen die Waffen und sowas,
aber so wirklich Substantielles
wissen wir über das Game gar nichts.
Wir wissen nur, was die Specialists
und Loadout-Perks sind.
Aber wir haben ein Video gemacht,
das alles, was DICE offiziell erklärt hat,
wenn ihr einen tieferen Blick auf diesen Modus wollt.
Auf technischem Niveau ist es schwer zu sagen,
wie gut es wird.
Es hat Sound keine Ahnung,
Portal nicht so wirklich eine Ahnung,
selbst All Out Warfare, wo sie fett Werbung gemacht haben
und man die Beta spielen kann,
so wirklich Ahnung davon hat man auch nicht.
Außer, dass man ein paar kurze Videos immer gesehen hat.
Dann haben sie angefangen mit ihren Story-Trailern,
da kam das mit Irish und ansonsten glaube ich nix.
Wo man sich halt fragt,
hätte man nicht vor,
Release eigentlich mindestens mal 5
dieser Story-Trailer droppen müssen?
Wenn man eine Story erzählen will,
dass man vor...
Ich mein, das Game ist unter einer Woche
von Release weg.
Wo sind denn die ganzen hunderten...
Wo ist denn die große Marketing-Trommel,
die rührt?
Ich merk davon gerade gar nix.
Bei Battlefield 3 hattest du komplette
Single-Player-Trips,
Single-Player-Missionen vor Release,
die du gucken konntest.
Nahezu komplette.
Ey, ist das Captain Price?
Der Typ sieht aus wie Captain Price.
Guckt euch mal den Typ an, der da rennt.
Der Typ, der Dude sieht echt...
Guck mal, der sieht aus wie Captain Price.
Naja, nee, nicht wirklich.
Aber auf den ersten Blick schon.
Hat halt auch so einen komischen Bart.
...
Nimmst du dir frei, Nö.
Es ist doch eh Freitag, wann man anfangen kann zu spielen.
Dann hab ich Freitag,
Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag, Montag
und dazu kommt
jetzt muss ich euch mal was poggerns...
porgerisches zeigen.
Ich habe ja eh Urlaub ab hier.
So, und ich habe festgestellt,
ich habe noch vier Tage Resturlaub.
Das heißt, ich kann,
hier habe ich eh frei,
hier habe ich eh frei.
Das heißt, ich nehme mir auf jeden Fall noch den Dienstag frei,
weil alles andere wäre bescheuert.
29.00 Uhr bin ich ja eh nicht da.
Dienstag, da müsste ich für einen Tag noch mal hin.
Hier nehme ich mir noch mal frei.
Und dann nehme ich einen Tag Kleidzeit
und die Woche davor noch mal.
Wenn das passt.
Ja, das heißt, dann habe ich quasi Urlaub
ab hier
bis nächstes Jahr.
19.11. bis nächstes Jahr.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt
kann ich ab 19.
24. im Battlefield spielen.
Und, tja.
Also, da muss ich mir keinen Urlaub
extra zu Release nehmen.
Also, was mich am meisten
excited, immer noch,
ist, dass es endlich mal wieder
ein modernes Battlefield ist.
Das Gesamtkonzept,
also,
das Gesamtding
aus, es ist ein modernes Battlefield
und es spielt sich auch relativ schnell
und zügig und so. Ich finde das gut.
Ich habe bei fast allem anderen Bedenken.
Habe ich ja in meinem letzten Video
auch, oder vorletzten Video erzählt.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz,
im Kern scheinen sie was richtig gemacht zu haben,
weil ich habe immer noch Bock drauf, jetzt zu spielen.
Diving in Headfirst.
Das ist auch so eine
Redewendung, die mir...
Das ist genauso wie Redewendung
Pushing Boundaries
und sowas. Es gibt so ein paar
Redewendungen, die gehen mir einfach richtig auf den Sack.
Wisst ihr,
es gibt eine Sache,
die mir, also,
so ein deutscher, also ein Spruch
auf Deutsch, der mir voll auf den Sack geht,
den die Leute zu allem sagen,
was sie gut finden.
Und das ist diese Kombination
richtig und wichtig.
Wenn ich das lese, kriege ich Anfälle.
Das sagt jeder zu allem, was er denkt,
für alles, was er denkt, was gut ist.
Wenn irgendwie einer sagt hier,
keine Ahnung,
alle Livestreamer sind kacke
und einer denkt, das ist oder treibt
richtig und wichtig.
Das ist doch
mittlerweile... Ernsthaft, ist das schon
gemimt, ja? Ist aber auch
verständlich.
Weißt du,
ein Arbeitgeber, dass du Streamer bist?
Ja,
der guckt sogar manchmal meine Videos.
Und letztens habe ich ihn sogar bei mir im Stream hier gesehen.
Das wusstet ihr nicht und ich habe auch nichts gesagt,
weil ich da nichts...
Ich wollte das jetzt nicht outen oder so.
Letztens war er sogar kurz im Stream.
Das ist richtig
und wichtig, das zu erwähnen.
Alter, das geht... Also diese Redewendung,
die geht mir wirklich auf den Keks.
Ist das nicht
von Monte? Nein, das ist nicht alles.
Diesen Spruch gibt es ja schon lange.
Schlimm. So, jetzt lassen wir uns weiter,
CheapBane.
At first.
Das kann man so sagen.
Alter Leute,
New World, es ist so krass am abkacken.
Ich hatte ja mal
eine Zeit lang, also ich habe ja New World nie gespielt,
also das Release nie gespielt, weil ich mir wusste,
dass Clusterfuckhoch10 ist.
Ich hatte ja richtig Spaß
die letzten 1-2 Wochen. Ich konnte mir
jeden Tag mehrere
Videos anschauen zu neuen New World
Glitches und was es für Glitches
gab, Alter.
Diese Sache mit wir freezen ist ja nur das
eine.
Du konntest Items dupen,
du konntest
HTML
injecten, wenn nicht sogar JavaScript,
weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Es war ein
abfuckhoch10.
Wirklich krasser Scheiß. Also, New World
ist in einem ganz, ganz grausamen
Zustand. Und wir gucken mal.
SteamStats New World.
Es ist irgendwie...
Es geht schneller, als ich mir das
gedacht habe. Es geht schneller als...
Die hatten eine Million am Anfang. Von ungefähr
einer Million sind die jetzt runter.
Die haben jetzt noch ein Drittel ungefähr.
Oh Mann.
Man muss sagen,
also,
vergiss nicht, das ist gerade los.
Das ist doch scheißegal.
Es ist auch Battlefield und Call of Duty Release.
Das ist scheißegal.
Das ist genauso, wie die Leute früher immer bei
MMOs, wo es den Bach runtergegangen ist,
gesagt haben, oh, es ist Sommer, die Leute spielen
weniger. Das ist doch scheißegal.
Also bei so einem Spielerverlust von
einem Drittel, das kannst du nicht auf
irgendwelche äußeren Faktoren schieben.
Das könntest du höchstens, hättest du das
damals auf World of Warcraft
Release vielleicht machen können, ja?
Aber dieses Kaliber
in MMOs haben wir jetzt ja nun nicht
gehabt. Und selbst da hat es
länger gedauert, wie die
MMOs Spieler verloren. Ich meine, man muss sich mal vorstellen,
das ist kein Subscription
based. Da steht 30 zu 9,
du musst etwas weiter aufmachen.
Ach ja. Hä? Ne, das ist doch
30 zu 9 ist doch rausgekommen.
Mehr geht doch, mehr geht doch nicht.
Mehr geht doch nicht, guck.
Das ist, das Game ist doch, das Game
ist doch quasi erst, ähm,
erst irgendwie
einen Monat oder so raus.
Ja, eineinhalb Monate
oder sowas. Oder drei,
ist jetzt eigentlich egal. Aber zumindest,
ja, äh, zumindest,
das ist ja nicht Subscription based.
Wenn es Subscription based,
guckt euch das mal an, das ist so krass. Wenn es
Subscription based gewesen wäre,
dann könnte man sagen, okay, ich verstehe
den Drop nach einem Monat, die Leute haben ihre
Subscription nicht, aber es ist nicht Subscription based.
Es ist einfach schlecht und hat Probleme.
Oh, es, fuck.
Ich meine, es muss, du musst es erst mal schaffen,
zwei Drittel deiner Spieler zu verlieren.
Das letzte Mal waren wir noch bei 40%,
was sie verloren haben. Jetzt haben sie quasi
zwei Drittel. Die haben es 60, naja,
okay, 66% der Spieler verloren.
Das ist brutal. Also, das
ist wirklich, aber gut, das Game ist auch
im Arsch, ja. Okay,
gucken wir uns das jetzt mal fertig an.
150K-Spieler ist auch nicht wenig.
Für den Anspruch, wie die gestartet haben,
und wir gehen ja mal, also ich gehe ja mal nicht
davon aus, dass es irgendwie jetzt schlagartig
stoppt. Ich meine, sieht das
irgendwie so aus, als würde diese Linie
aufhören, nach unten zu gehen?
Warte mal, Steam
New World, stimmt, wir müssen uns
Steam Rezession angucken, das ist lustig.
Die interessante Frage ist, wie viele
Spieler haben Max Level erreicht? Ach, bestimmt,
bestimmt einen Teil.
Bestimmt, bestimmt.
Aber das ist ja nochmal
ein Beweis dafür, dass es in Failure
MMO ist, wenn du Max Level erreichst und dann
nichts zu tun hast und alles
den Bach runter geht. Das ist ja nicht
Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Level-Prozess in
einem MMO sollte ja eigentlich nur ein Teil
davon sein.
Ich hab's gesagt, ich hab's, Leute, ich hab's von
Anfang an gesagt. Leute haben gesagt, ach,
nee, Max, die kriegen das schon hin. Nein, die kriegen das nicht hin.
Das war für mich direkt, direkt bei der Beta klar.
Age of Vampires 4,
ja, das soll richtig gut sein. So, wir gucken
uns das jetzt hier erstmal an, was er dazu sagt.
Ja, es gibt immer Leute, die so Games
hartnäckig verteidigen. Und du weißt
ja, du hast dann immer so die gleichen Ausreden.
Wenn's dir nicht gefällt, dann spiel's
doch nicht. Ja, machen ja auch
ganz viele offensichtlich.
Ja, es machen ja ganz
viele.
Oder die Leute dann so nach dem Motto, das ist
doch alles nicht schlimm, ich habe meinen
Spaß. Das ist ja schön für dich,
wenn du deinen Spaß daran hast, was aber nicht
die Probleme weniger problematisch
macht, die das Spiel hat. Ist ja schön und gut, wenn
jemand Einzeles sagt, dass er seinen Spaß hat,
soll er weiterspielen und gut ist, soll er Spaß haben,
habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mit. Das ändert
aber nichts daran, dass das Spiel
Fehler und Probleme ohne Ende hat.
So.
Ähm.
Vielleicht erzählt er ja ein paar.
Ja.
Ich glaube, den Anfang haben wir gar nicht gehört.
Okay.
Ja.
Also, ich habe mir das ein bisschen genauer angeguckt, weil
mich interessiert hat, was da los ist. Also, du
konntest quasi im Chat posten
von New World, du
konntest quasi Link
Tags in
den Chat posten
und das hat funktioniert.
Es war nicht nur so, dass
du damit nicht
quasi den Chat kaputt
machen konntest.
Du konntest auch
irgendwie falsche
Items linken, die du gar nicht
hast.
So. Aber wisst ihr,
was der Fix
von Amazon war?
Der Fix
von Amazon war
String Contains.
Das war
der Fix
von Amazon.
Doch, doch.
Das ist der, das ist der, das war der Fix von Amazon.
Das Problem ist jetzt aber,
dass du ohne Probleme,
dass du ja mit allen möglichen
anderen Tags auch machen konntest.
So. Also, es ist,
ich glaube, ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es gefixt.
Aber,
Amazon ist einfach krass unfähig,
was das Ganze angeht. Ach ja, und dann gab es übrigens
noch einen geilen Bug.
Weiß nicht, ob er das noch erzählen wird, aber das war
mein persönlicher, mein persönlicher Lieblingsbug
von dem, was ich gesehen habe.
Du konntest
unendlich XP farmen,
indem du
an das, an das Quest Board gegangen bist und irgendwie
eine, was weiß ich, Fische-5-Fische-Quest angenommen hast.
Dann bist du zum Marketplace gegangen.
Und hast dir diese 5 Fische gekauft,
ähm, zum Quest abgeben.
Davor hast du sie allerdings wieder in den Marketplace reingesetzt.
Also hast du sie aus dem Marketplace gekauft,
hast sie in den Marketplace reingesetzt.
Normalerweise sollten die dann aus deinem Inventar verschwinden.
Sind sie wohl auch, allerdings
intern irgendwie nicht.
Dann bist du zum Quest Board gegangen.
Und dann hatte ich das Quest Board quasi
die Fische abgezogen, die du eigentlich gar nicht mehr hattest,
hatte die XP gegeben und du konntest zum, zum Marketplace zurück
und deine Fische im Auktionshaus canceln und du hast sie wieder gehabt.
Du konntest quasi so unendlich XP farmen.
Das war auch bester, bester Bug.
So fehl, das ist so fehl.
Ja.
Du konntest übrigens, äh, also du konntest,
du konntest glaube ich sogar Items dupen, aber Gold auf jeden Fall.
Und das war irgendein Trading Bug.
Ich krieg das, ich krieg, also es gab, es gab zwei Gold Duplication Bugs.
Also Dupe, Gold Dupe Bugs.
Ähm, du konntest einmal mit dem Charakter Transfer dupen.
Also du konntest quasi irgendwie dein Charakter, äh, du konntest irgendwie,
ich krieg, ich, wie gesagt, nachdem ich selbst nicht spiele,
ich kann, ich kenne sowas wie, du konntest irgendwie, äh, äh, äh, äh,
Charakter Transfer machen
und vorher dein Geld traden
und dann hast du es nach dem Charakter Transfer wieder gehabt
auf dem neuen Server und konntest zurück transfern, das Gold war verdoppelt.
Oder aber du konntest auch über das Trade Window irgendwas, irgendwas buggen.
Also das Geld, dass du das Geld wiederbekommen hast.
Also es war richtig broken as fuck.
Du spielst jeden Tag Outpost Rush.
Es ist immer noch so, dass die Leute gebannt werden,
weil sie, äh, reported werden.
Das funktioniert ja nicht.
Selbst das funktioniert ja nicht.
Das funktioniert ja nicht mit den Bans.
Ähm, äh, was sagt der Chat, wenn man, was, man kann Bans umgehen,
indem man einfach seine E-Mail ändert?
Was?
Ja, aber echt äußerst amateurhaft, wenn das, wenn das wirklich funktioniert.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Fuck, was hat er gesagt?
Track the people abusing it and...
Achso!
Achso! Ja, das, das, das funktioniert ja auch nicht.
Die können ja gar nicht richtig nachvollziehen,
wer das gemacht hat.
Da muss ich mal vorstellen, das ist auch relativ schwierig.
Erstens sind, sind die bekannt dafür, falsche Leute zu bannen.
Weil, weil unfähig.
Und, ähm, die Leute, die Gold, äh, gedubt haben,
die haben ja Gold verschickt per, äh, Ingame Post und Marketplace und sonst was.
Selbst wenn du das tracken kannst,
was willst du, was willst du machen?
Willst du jede Ingame Transaction rückgängig machen?
Der letzten, äh, zwei Wochen?
Was latest player can unban?
Wirklich? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Players can...
Haha, was?
Wait a, wait, wait a minute!
Was?
It appears that Steam family sharing allows the player to evade a ban?
And create a new account.
The same key, but it gets worse.
Apparently all it takes to get around a ban is just changing the email address as...
Hä? Moment, Moment, Moment!
Ich muss mein Steam-Account-Email-Adresse ändern, dann bin ich unbanned?
Ist das, benutzen die das irgendwie als Identifier oder wie?
Kein, kein eindeutig...
Oh Gott, die sind so krass unfähig!
Wie kann man so unfähig sein?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Ich mein, das sind doch keine Kack-Noobs!
Wie kriegen die sowas hin?
Warum...
Okay, gucken wir mal, ist noch einer.
...are issuing bans.
The final issue is pretty severe.
Players discovered sharing the game with yourself via Steam's family share system
or changing the email of your Steam account will actually let you to continue to play the game
if you've been banned from the game.
Again, the developers are working on a fix for this,
but this is a massive issue as it will allow exploiters and cheaters to get back into the game.
Wetten? Wetten? Die können dich dann auch nicht richtig tracken, wenn du deine E-Mail-Adresse änderst.
Also mal angenommen, du hast Gold gedubt as fuck und du änderst deine E-Mail-Adresse
und da können sie dich gar nicht richtig tracken, würde mich nicht wundern.
... having such a rough week.
The devs are releasing a blog post outlining all the progress that they've made on these bugs,
what actions they're taking next...
Das ist so eine Shitshow, das Ding, Alter!
...you can expect some significant updates in the next few weeks that iron out a lot of the problems.
Der Wahnsinn, das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, ey!
The critical consensus is in on Call of Duty Vanguard.
Reviewers are saying the game is a decent outing for the franchise,
but that it serves as more of a stopgap between Cold War and the next Modern Warfare game
than as a standout title.
Before the game was officially revealed, leaks suggested Vanguard was a rush job
throwing together COD World War II's assets with Modern Warfare's mechanics.
And while those rumors never held much weight,
it's clear that this year's title only makes minor iterations
on the template that Modern Warfare established.
Ach nee, Call of Duty macht jedes Jahr minor iterations.
Guckt euch mal FIFA an, FIFA macht auch jedes Jahr nur minor iterations.
Das ist ja mittlerweile Geschäftsmodell bei vielen Serien geworden.
Dass die jedes Jahr, oder wenn es so was ist wie, was halt mehrere Jahre läuft,
die machen immer nur minor iterations.
Die gehen null Risiko ein.
Das ist immer der gleiche Scheiß.
Deswegen ist das auch so ausgelutschter Scheiß mittlerweile alles.
Und es gibt nur noch Serien.
This feature is a nice addition, but it's certainly not as extensive as, say, Battlefield.
So it doesn't feel that fresh, since it's very static and predictable.
An sich finde ich's eigentlich ganz cool, muss ich sagen.
Also ich hätte echt keine Probleme mal wieder, wenn's einen ganz guten World War II-Shooter geben würde,
echt keinen Schmerz mit.
Das Problem, warum ich's mir nicht kaufen werde, ist schlicht und ergreifend die Kombination.
Es ist Call of Duty und es hat quasi Public Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Gegen Skill-Based Matchmaking im Ranked hab ich ja nix.
Ranked ohne Skill-Based Matchmaking funktioniert ja logischerweise nicht, da wär's nicht Ranked.
Das Bettopfer ist am Start.
Danke für den Prime-Sub.
Dann kann man aber wenigstens einen Schwanzvergleich machen mit seinem Rank.
Aber Public Skill-Based Matchmaking ist einfach der größte Scheiß, der jemals erfunden wurde,
wo ich keine Lust drauf hab, das zu spielen.
This thing is also a little bit of a sticking point for some reviews.
Returning to such a well-explored era with World War II,
when other popular titles are pushing boundaries in different eras,
makes Vanguard feel a little too familiar for some.
Zombies make smart updates that help new players get involved.
Ein sehr diverser Cast an Characters.
Das muss heutzutage so sein.
But there's no big story to play through until the game's first season launches on December 2nd.
That's also when Vanguard...
Äh, Cedi sagt, Activision ist der Multiplayer von COD,
egal, denen geht's nur um Warzone-Integration.
Na, wenn denen der Multiplayer egal wäre, dann hätte...
Also, wenn die sich nichts versprechen würden von dem Multiplayer,
dann würden die Multiplayer schlicht und ergreifend nicht machen.
Das heißt, sie müssen damit irgendwas bezwecken.
Ja, natürlich, du hast recht, es ist sicherlich auch um Warzone-Verkäufe
beziehungsweise Warzone-Unlocks, wie auch immer, irgendwas anzuheizen,
aber ganz so einfach kann's nicht sein.
Es gibt sicherlich eine große Anzahl an Call of Duty-Fans,
die immer noch lieber...
Oder sagen wir mal,
die mit Warzone nichts großartig anfangen können
und die Multiplayer spielen wollen.
Also ganz so einfach ist es nicht.
Und dann gibt's auch kein Skill-Based-Match,
also dann könnten sie auch Skill-Based-Match-Making sparen und sowas,
wenn sie da nichts reinstecken wollen.
Das ist ganz gezielt drinne,
dass die Leute,
die quasi...
Dass so diese, ach, ich lock mich einmal die Woche für zwei Stunden abends ein,
äh, was weiß ich,
wenn meine Kinder beim Fußball spielen
und meine Frau irgendwie, äh, auf dem Elternabend ist,
dann lock ich mich mal zwei Stunden ein und spiele eine Runde Vanguard.
So Leute sind das, die du für die Skill-Based-Matchmaking gemacht hast.
Warzone goes live.
It seems like Vanguard represents another year
where the more popular Call of Duty experience
will remain in Warzone for many players.
That said, it also sounds like Vanguard
is a solid experience despite its shortcomings.
Major game delays were announced this week...
Also, ich will nicht wissen, was klar bei Blizzard intern los sein muss,
was Overwatch angeht.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das haben die angekündigt,
ich glaube, 2018 oder so.
Und seitdem ist ja auch der Content für Overwatch 1 quasi nicht vorhanden.
Also, da kommt ab und zu mal eine Deathmatch-Map oder so.
Die letzten Jahre ist in Overwatch nichts passiert, gar nichts.
Sowohl lore-technisch kam...
Na gut, da kam wenigstens ab und zu mal ein Comic oder irgendwas,
oder ich weiß nicht, ob es auch ein Comic war oder so.
Aber ich glaube,
es ist nichts ganz Unbedeutendes.
Aber Ingame-Content mit gar nichts.
Gar nichts. So.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
die wollten das schon in nächster Zeit releasen.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen
haben sie sich umorientiert,
was es werden soll.
Jeff Kaplan ist nicht ohne Grund weg.
Und ich habe keinerlei Hoffnung für Overwatch 2. Null.
Ach so, mitbekommen,
dass McCree unbenannt wird.
Ja, McCree ist doch schon unbenannt worden.
Da ist jetzt, wie heißt er, ich glaube,
Cassidy Cole-Cassidy, oder?
Nee.
Cassidy Cole-Cassidy?
Irgendwas mit Cassidy, irgendwas.
Ich weiß nicht, wie McCree jetzt heißt.
Aber da muss ich sagen,
das haben die total insofern schon taktisch gut,
hat ein gutes Setup.
Wie heißt denn McCree jetzt?
McCree...
Cassidy...
McCree... Cassidy...
Heißt jetzt Cole Cassidy.
So rum.
Das haben die ganz gut setupt,
weil in einem der ursprünglichen
Lore-Videos oder was es war,
wurde ja schon quasi gesagt,
dass McCree quasi nicht
sein echter Name ist.
Was man ja sich auch denken könnte.
Aber das haben sie insofern ganz gut integriert.
Der Grund, warum McCree unbenannt wurde,
ja...
An sich hätte ich ja da gar keine Schmerzen mit.
Ich finde es auch nicht schlecht.
Aber es ist so eine typische Blizzard-Geschichte,
so nach dem Motto
Welt, seht her, wir kümmern uns um die Probleme.
Und in Wirklichkeit benennen wir halt bloß
einen Charakter um, ohne dass sich irgendwie
nennenswert bei Blizzard was ändert.
Blizzard hat überhaupt kein Interesse daran,
dass da irgendwas aufgearbeitet, irgendwas geändert wird,
solange der Hubel rollt im Endeffekt.
Ja, ist weg.
Was ich lustig finde,
weil der ehemalige Blizzard-Chef
ist ja quasi erst vor ein paar Monaten abgedankt.
Jetzt ist die neue Blizzard-Chefin abgedankt.
Und mal gucken, was jetzt kommt.
Wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt irgend so ein Activision-Stonks-Anzugmann
und es wird nicht besser.
... by the end of the year.
Her departure is just the latest
in a string of exits by prominent executives...
Blizzard ist das beste Beispiel für,
was passiert,
wenn aus...
Wir machen Spiele,
die wir selbst gerne spielen würden,
zu...
Also Blizzard kommt von
wir machen Spiele, die wir selbst gerne spielen würden,
oder die uns selbst Spaß machen,
wir machen Spiele so, wie wir sie selbst mögen würden,
hin zu
wir haben irgendwelche Stonks-Leute
im Anzug ohne Ahnung von Spielen als Chefs.
Blizzard ist das beste Beispiel für diese Entwicklung.
Anders kann man es auch nicht erklären.
Das hat angefangen mit...
...
Im Endeffekt schon während dem ersten Overwatch.
Das hat eigentlich schon angefangen mit StarCraft 2.
Das war absehbar, dass es bergrunter ging.
Ohne WoW wäre Blizzard gefühlt dead.
Gut, das ist ja schon lange so.
World of Warcraft ist ja quasi das Ding von Blizzard schlechthin gewesen
oder ist es, glaube ich, immer noch.
Wobei man sagen muss, Blizzard hat auch andere Dinge.
Gerade Hearthstone schaffelt auch gut Kohle.
... of whom were named in California's lawsuit.
They announced that their next-gen PGA Tour game is delayed.
It was previously scheduled for a 2022 launch,
but they pushed it to a later date.
What makes this delay a big deal is that
golf games have exploded in popularity recently,
thanks to the success of Golf with Your Friends
and PGA Tour 2K21.
EA's PGA Tour game is their return to the franchise after...
What the fuck? Was war das?
Moment mal.
Es ist Golf. Okay, das habe ich verstanden, aber...
Was war das für ein Golf-Typ?
Warum ist das irgendein Typ in der Wüstenkammer, wo der Golf spielt?
Ist das Golf mit Killstreaks oder...
Was ist das?
Ist es der Battlefield 4 Sniper? Weiß nicht.
Mal gucken, wie der Battlefield 4 Sniper aussieht.
Ey, das hat tatsächlich gewisse Ähnlichkeiten zum Battlefield 4 Sniper,
aber das ist er nicht.
Wobei, das ist der Battlefield 4 Sniper, Leute.
Das ist der Battlefield 4 Sniper.
Warum ist der Battlefield 4 Sniper in einem Golf-Spiel?
Guck mal, das ist der... Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Hier. Das ist der Battlefield 4 Sniper.
Warum ist der Battlefield 4 Sniper in einem Golf-Spiel?
Alles verlaufen.
... der Return to the Franchise after six years
and is highly anticipated since it will be cutting-edge next-gen tech.
Konami also delayed their major 1.0 update for eFootball 2020.
Doch, das ist ja auch so eine Shitshow gewesen schlechthin, ey.
Meine Güte, ich glaube, das ist eines der schlecht bewerteten Spiele letzter Zeit gewesen.
Hast du Edge of Empires 4 gespielt?
Nein, aber ich habe 500 Stunden oder so in dem Teil davor.
In den Teilen davor.
Ich muss mir das unbedingt noch kaufen.
... the backlash to the launch has been severe
and many view this 1.0 update as a patch that will actually make eFootball a game
instead of a glorified demo.
The final delay announced this week was by XCOM developers...
Juckt mich null.
Juckt mich ja mal sowas von nicht.
... and is a turn-based strategy game.
Ist mir sowas von egal.
... pretty much stellar track record with their previous titles.
I think most people are thinking the delay will be well worth it in the long run.
Forza Horizon 5 is shaping up to be one of the best-reviewed games of 2021.
Am Start.
... praising its visual presentation, gameplay and approachable mechanics.
Ist mir auch vollkommen egal.
... available for select pre-order customers and user reviews have also been very positive.
The game looks cutting-edge and features advanced technologies like ray tracing.
Like past Forza games, Horizon 5 leans into the arcade gameplay and seasonal challenges.
It's not so much a sim-racing game as it is an action-racing experience.
Arena shooter Splitgate added custom matches.
This year the game exploded in popularity thanks to its cross-play beta
and has maintained a pretty healthy player base.
Switch Splitgate.
Halbherzig in Grenzen.
Muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt auf die Spielerzahlen auswirken,
aber meistens sind Streams ein ganz guter Indikator dafür.
Ist halt auch 10 Uhr morgens. Na ja, bei uns.
... since late summer.
It's projected to stay in beta until sometime next year, but is getting regular content updates in seasonal events.
Custom matches let players tweak all sorts of mode, map and player variables.
Irgendwie erinnert mich das trotzdem ein bisschen an Halo.
... Halo's Forge Mode or Battlefield Portal, but the developers plan to add a Forge Mode of their own eventually.
Getting your hands on one of Intel's two new CPUs is proving to be a challenge.
Orders for the higher-end models seem to have outpaced demand
and we're already seeing listings for nearly double MSRP on sites like...
Es ist so ziemlich schwierig an alles zu kommen gerade in dieser Richtung.
... eBay. The lower-end model is doing much better though and is available at MSRP from many retailers.
Wir gucken mal. Tatsächlich, das gucken wir mal kurz, Zack.
Splitgate Steam Stats. Lasst mal kurz schauen.
Okay, es ist nicht... Also den Mega-Hype konnten sie nicht halten.
Sag mal so innerhalb von einem Viertel, also innerhalb von irgendwie vier Monaten
sind sie halt runter von 67.000 Spieler auf 5.000.
Wobei das nicht schlecht ist, muss man sagen, ne?
Also 5.000 Peak-Spieler im Steam-Vergleich ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Guck mal hier, also ich mein, ähm, da bist du schon unter Top 100 oder so mit 5.000 Spielern.
Das ist gar nicht mal so mies.
... it offers the most bang for your buck.
The more significant issue though is the supporting hardware.
Motherboards and DDR5 RAM are in short supply at many retailers.
Es ist alles on short supply.
Leute, ich will mir seit, seit Jahren neuen PC kaufen, könnt's vergessen.
... products have been this past year, but you'll still have to hunt for a reasonable price.
Mein PC ist jetzt vier Jahre alt, ziemlich genau.
Before we get to our final story of this week, I just wanted to say thanks for tuning in.
If there's any big stories you think that we missed this week, let us know in the comments.
We'll be back on Monday with a new video, so stay tuned for that.
The Season 11 update for Apex Legends has some potential issues Respawn are working on.
The biggest one is an issue with tracking Battle Pass XP.
... it manifests as your Battle Pass badge not updating as you would level up.
respawn
Respawn tweeted, that the problem will be fixed in the game's next major patch, which could take a few weeks.
Ich hab auch eine Tausend-Acht-Spiegel. Ja, drei Sticke.
Thank you so much for watching and I'll catch you next time. This is LevelCap signing off.
Wenn ich mein übertakte, sind das, keine Ahnung, vielleicht 15%, wo das Ding noch schneller ist.
Also Single-Core und Dual-Core.
Also natürlich, ab 8-Coren wird es natürlich mehr, weil meiner hat bloß 6 Kerne.
Aber mehr brauchst du nicht.
Also der Witz ist halt, mein 8700K, ein bisschen übertaktet, ist im Prinzip auch nur, sagen wir mal, 15-20% langsamer als die aktuelle Top-CPU.
Ja.
Ja gut, dann nehmen wir irgendeinen anderen. Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Sag mir irgendeine sinnvolle Sache. Die Seite ist scheiße. Ja, okay.
Dann sag mir eine andere Seite, wo man das gut vergleichen kann.
Hier. Worth it.
Übertakten-Stream haben wir doch damals gemacht.
Wir haben das doch live hier im Stream mit Elgato-Capture-Karte noch übertaktet, mein Rechner.
Dann hab ich ihn geköpft und dann ging's ab.
Ja, da hab ich meine Zweifel.
Da hab ich meine Zweifel, ob das wirklich so ist.
Also mich würden da schon ordentliche Benchmarks...
...Vergleiche interessieren.
Also das mit 20-30% halte ich tatsächlich für realistisch.
Hat sich da in den letzten Jahren jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel getan.
Muss man mal gucken.
Zumindest hat es eh keinen Sinn, weil ich kaufe mir jetzt keinen neuen Rechner.
Warum sollte ich mir ausgerechnet jetzt einen neuen Rechner kaufen?
Ich brauche ja eine neue Grafikkarte.
Und was kostet mich aktuell eine 3090?
Zumal ich auch keine 3090 eigentlich mehr kaufen will.
Oh, der Preisschirm ist abgeschissen.
P.P. Hands.
Physics, danke schön für den Sub.
Was kostet so eine 3090? 2000 Euro?
Das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Alter.
Nicht normal.
Was ist los, Rosario?
Selten so einen schlechten Tag gehabt wie Freitag.
Oh, Painschamp.
1&1 hat Merch-Konflikte ausgelöst.
Was? Wie schafft es denn 1&1 Merch-Konflikte auszulösen?
Also man kann sich über einen Provider sicherlich öfters beschweren.
Aber was hat Painschamp?
Was hat Painschamp?
Was hat dein Provider mit Merch-Konflikten zu tun?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Das musst du mir etwas genauer erklären.
Das checke ich nicht.
Der Pi kam an, aber fehlte ein Kabel.
FeelsBadMan.
Am Samstag nach Uni.
P.P. Hands.
Was hat 1&1 mit Merch-Konflikten zu tun?
Hä?
Es lohnt sich nicht wirklich.
Ah, du bist Consultant für die 1&1 Backend-Software.
Okay, dann ergibt das natürlich Sinn.
Painschamp.
Ja, dann ist es natürlich doof.
Dann verstehe ich auch, wie das Merch-Konflikt da auslösen kann.
Wobei die meisten Merch-Konflikte gar nicht so wild sind.
Zumindest bei mir.
Oder bei uns.
Aber es kommt natürlich immer darauf an, von welchem Umfang man spricht.
Fertig-PCs, okay.
Drei Wochen Arbeit von Arsch gewesen.
Massive Painschamp.
Das ist ja am Preisschamp echt ganz gut.
Man sieht die Preisschamp.
Man sieht die Preisentwicklung von drei Monaten.
Leider habe ich dieses mit dem ein Jahr auf drei Monate gestellt.
Das ist ein Bug.
Und ich habe keinen Bock, das zu fixen.
Guck mal, ein Jahr und drei Monate ist das Gleiche.
Es geht sieben Tage, drei Monate, ein Jahr ist dann das Gleiche.
Das ist broken.
Das ist ein Feature, genau.
Aber das hier ist eigentlich der UVP.
Wann gibt es denn den Nachfolger?
Nvidia, was ist denn das dann?
4.090?
Insider rechnet mit enormem Strom.
Stromverbrauch, ja, das Zeug verbraucht immer viel.
Sommer 2022 und möglicher Release im Oktober 2.
Oh, oh.
550 Watt.
Na, aber abwarten, abwarten.
Ich kaufe mir keinen neuen Rechner.
Wisst ihr, dass es das erste Mal ist, dass ich in so einer Situation bin, wie es gab?
Diese Situation, wie jetzt, gab es noch nie.
Also bisher war es eigentlich so, dass ich mir immer gedacht habe,
habe hey ich könnte mir mal wieder neuen rechner kaufen da war ich entweder zu
faul für zu faul zum umstellen zu faulen zum zusammenstellen und irgendwann
dachte jetzt wird es aber doch mal zeit und habe ich geguckt was es gibt und hat
mir dann eingekauft und jetzt ist es so jetzt stelle ich fest okay ich kann mir
gar keinen kaufen und ich hoffe einfach nur dass meiner noch eine weile hält
wohl hat schon vier jahre alt ist es gibt ja keine möglichkeit aktuell sich
den ordentlichen rechner zu kaufen so richtig weil wenn wenn will ich halt
auch was ordentliches und was ordentliches heißt bei mir einfach
seit seit seit ein paar jahren so mehr oder weniger schnellste was es gibt und
ich sehe es kann ich sehe es halt nicht ein 3000 euro zu bezahlen für eine
grafikkarte ja das ist halt das ist halt dumm deswegen hoffe ich ja auch meine
tuts noch eine weile ich will also eigentlich hatte ich ja
letztes jahr schon formieren
preis und pc also ich habe schon vor zwei jahren von den reisen pc zu bauen
dann habe ich gedacht man holt sie die 5.000 das serie und dann ging das
eigentlich alles downhill ja ach mal gucken aktuell tut das ja und man muss
ja auch sagen die kombination als 8700 kar und 1080 ti ist ja vollkommen
ausreichend ich stell battle viel einfach auf niedrige details und aufgeht
so dass man jeff ps denkst du das nächste battlefield spiel spielt wieder
in der vergangenheit
mal bis es aktuell rauskommt was das nächste macht keine ahnung ich persönlich fände es ja
gut wenn die wirklich also wenn das wenn das denn in einem halbwegs guten zustand ist spaß macht
spielbar ist dass sie battlefield 20 42 einfach mal drei vier jahre supporten und das aktuell
apropos ach ja hier das sind die sind es die leaks zu battlefield 20 42 wäre gespannt ich habe sogar
in der beta 120 fps teilweise erreicht und die lief beschissen hallo was ist mit reddit los was
mit reddit los zack holt was auch immer die da machen was habe ich falsch gemacht gott battlefield
20 42 early wie hat er das doch fake oder also wenn das das einzige ist was er gepostet das ist
doch fake ich meine das kann durchaus aus dem game sein aber also das könnte durchaus aus dem spiel
wein aber gibt auch videos wo gibt es ja noch sachen von ihm ich habe keine nda dafür unterschrieben
ich habe keine nda dafür unterschrieben
geschweige denn für für reddit leaks hat hat er da noch irgendetwas dazu geschrieben oder
ein in das sieht sehr sehr echt aus warum kann er schon spiel ich meine die server dürften noch
gar nicht da sein war proof classic battlefield 3 der ist tatsächlich schon am start der spielt
mit gar keiner anscheinend gibt es ein server browser sieht man das main menü irgendwo
xbox well i've been kicked out raus ja na ja moment das ist für pauses für portal das portal
server browser hat das war ja klar ich rede vom normalen battlefield ja das ist legit gehe ich
ganz stark davon aus es ist legit allerdings so wirklich viel sehen tut man jetzt ja nicht
warum man schon spielen kann ist natürlich die große frage warum die server schon da sind ist
da gibt es ja noch die geheimnisse bis hin zu diesem
wie einige yugioh battle royale 2 verband sind ja peng Sig Florida war es aber auch noch eine gute fragen na ja wahrscheinlich weil sie selbst noch testen wollen warum es nicht irgendwie gesichert ist keine ahnung du kannst es ja nicht starten wenn du viel erwartet hast normalerweise naja so wirklich viel spannendes ist jetzt danach nicht zu sehen was hältst du von an raid abstand nicht dass es schlecht wäre oder so ich habe damit noch nicht gemacht ich wüsste doch nicht wofür na ja ist jetzt recht unspektakulär aber wurde eine typ auf reddit recht hatte is dass es jetzt 30 milliarden league videos geben wird und ich habe auch noch die gleiche frage an dem
das sagt der reddit der hat jetzt recht hat und ich habe das recht hatte dass es jetzt 30 milliarden league videos geben wird und ich habe auch noch die gleiche frage an dem
Ähm, dass es jetzt 30 Milliarden
Leak-Videos geben wird
Hehehehe
Naja, egal
Es ist, es ist in der Woche, wissen wir es
Er hat paar Fragen beantwortet
Okay
Schauen wir mal schnell
Der Aaron Frogger, ach ne, Frogger
Und jetzt
Hier
Er spielt on Xbox
Das stimmt ja nicht
Na gut, es hält sich sehr in Grenzen
Egal
Äh, komm mal weiter
Oh, hier werden MikroTik-Switcher empfohlen
Zeig mal her, ob ich da zustimmen kann
Äh, ja, der ist tatsächlich ganz gut
Aber ich würde eher noch einen nehmen
Wobei, worum ging es denn überhaupt
Ein paar
Was
Kann mir einer Empfehlung geben von Max
Für einen, was ist denn ein Max-Port-Switch
Du willst
Achso, 8 Ports
8-Port-Switch-Manage plus PoE
Ah, plus PoE
Haha, okay, plus PoE ist das Problem
Weil
Äh, ohne PoE hätte ich dir den hier empfohlen
Moment
Zeig
Ohne PoE hätte ich dir den hier
Wobei, ich bin gar nicht sicher, wer hat da PoE
Ich glaube, der hat keinen PoE
Hätte ich dir den hier empfohlen
Weil, da ist es eigentlich preis-leistungsmäßig
So ziemlich der beste Switch, den du gerade kaufen kannst
8 Ports Gigabit, 2 Ports
SA4 plus 10 Gigabit
Aber ich glaube, der hat kein
Ich glaube, der hat kein PoE
Ja, mit PoE muss man
Dann wüsste ich jetzt nichts
In der Regel
Wollte man den Kram nicht irgendwie filtern?
Nach PoE oder nicht PoE?
Ich will nicht PoE in, ich will PoE out
PoE in brauche ich nicht
Ich brauche PoE out
PoE
Ja, aber das
Ich würde halt einen nehmen
Mit 10G
Mindestens mal mit 10G ablenken
Alles andere suckt doch
In der heutigen Zeit
Das hier macht einen ganz guten Eindruck
24 Ports
4x SFP plus
379 Euro
Klasse, so einschneiß
Aber es sind mehr Ports wie du willst
Ja ne, da fällt mir nichts gescheites ein, was passt
Stonks, der hat eindeutig zu wenig Geld
Da brauche ich mehr
Was ist denn Passive PoE?
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie
Irgendwas, was Mikrotik da treibt
Entweder 24V, 48V
Ach, kein Schimmer
PoE-Standards 0
Aber wofür 10G im Homebereich?
Die Frage ist hier, warum kein 10G?
Vor allem wenn man sich jetzt einen neuen Switch kauft
Zumindest mal 2
2 10G Ports sind relativ günstig
Und man hat die Möglichkeit
Damit halt was zu machen
Wenn man will
Kann es ja auch sein lassen
Aber, also heute
Warum?
Also gerade wenn es ein Switch ist
Hier für zentral am Schreibtisch oder so
Ich würde mir eigentlich nichts mehr holen
Ohne 10G
2 10G Ports
Sogar der Switch auf meinem Basteltisch hat 2x 10G Ports
Ja
Ok, gucken wir mal weiter
Was haben wir sonst noch schönes zu gucken?
Der Lockpicking Lawyer ist am Start
Ja, den Vanguard-Test von der GameStar
Wollte ich mir noch angucken
Ob sich das Spiel in irgendeiner Art und Weise lohnt
Mal gucken, mal gucken, wer den Test spricht
Je nachdem, behalte ich mir vor, das abzubrechen
Mal gucken
Ah, ist das
Ist das Dimitri?
Weiß ich nicht
Wer ist das?
Nein, das ist nicht Dimitri
Das ist Christian Fritz-Schneider
Alles klar
Ach er, ist das
Ne, das ist nicht der mit dem Bart, oder?
Der aussieht wie von Vikings
Läuft das hier doppelt?
So, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
... das Ingame-Material
Und dafür sehr viele Szenen aus
Vorberechneten Zwischensequenzen
Zu sehen gab, hatte ich durchaus Sorge
Was da wohl auf uns zukommen würde
Zumal die Prämisse
Rund um ein bunt zusammengewürfeltes Team
Von alliierten Spezialisten
Das zum Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
Mitten in Berlin auf einer
Geheimmission unterwegs ist
Ich muss das anders machen mit dem Sound
So hört sich das richtig kacke an
Ich muss gerade mal reloaden
In Berlin auf einer
Geheimmission unterwegs ist
Ziemlich konstruiert und bei der Zusammensetzung
Der Gruppe sogar
Gerecht anbiedernd wirkte
Und so irreweit hergeholt wäre so ein Vorwurf
Vielleicht auch gar nicht
Schließlich freuen sich die Entwickler an ihren
Zusammensetzung der Gruppe relativ anbiedernd
Möchte er damit umschreiben, dass das quasi
Ähm, besonders
Divers sein muss, weil es so
Shitstorms gibt
Was ja auch garantiert so wäre
Ich habe Videos unverhohlen darüber, dass der
Zweite Weltkrieg ja zum Glück an so vielen
Tollen, diversen Schauplätzen stattfand
In großartigen, diversen Locations
Überall auf der Welt
Es ist schwer nicht zu freuen, wenn man
Die unglaublichen Kämpfe betrachtet
Der Grad der Geschmacklosigkeit hat da also schon längst
Einen neuen Höchststand erreicht
Aber ich will hier nicht die Moralapostel spielen
Ich habe schließlich auch jedes Jahr Spaß
An den Ballerbuden von Activision
Und ich habe auch kein Problem damit am Computer
Krieg zu spielen, weil ich den Unterschied zwischen
Fiktion und Realität kenne
Ja, dabei ist die Lautstärke irgendwie
Merkwürdig, am Anfang viel lauter
Und jetzt leiser
Das geht jetzt
Denn selbst in dem einzigen längeren Abschnitt
Der vor Release zu sehen war
Nämlich ein Level in Stalingrad
Wirkten die Szenen manchmal noch merkwürdig unfertig
Hier fehlt zum Beispiel die halbe Beleuchtung
Das
Das wundert mich nicht
Das wird auch nie im Leben wieder gepatcht
Moment
Das ist aber Vorschau, das ist Vorschau gewesen
Was ist das jetzt
MonkaS
Dieses Video wird präsentiert als
Nein
Jetzt fangen die auch schon damit an
Ja, das wäre ich jetzt auch voll ausgegangen
Es ist ganz schön gutes Wetter in Stalingrad, oder?
Chat
Also das hat ja gerade einer geschrieben
Aber
Ist schon ein erstaunlich gutes Wetter
Und verglichen mit dem fast schon
Experimentellen Cold War
Vom letzten Jahr, das sich ja über
Weite Strecken
Cold War, ich habe ganz ehrlich
Ich glaube im Multiplayer habe ich gar nicht gespielt
Oder ganz kurz nur gespielt
Ich wollte eigentlich die Black Ops Kampagne mir angucken
Und ich muss sagen, die hat echt viel
Verschenktes Potential gehabt
Die Ansätze waren echt da, aber die haben
Verschenktes Potential gehabt in der Kampagne
Eher wie ein Agenten-Thriller spielte
Ich finde immer noch
Die beste Call of Duty Kampagne ist für mich
Also die drei, sagen wir mal die Top 3
Die Top 3 Kampagnen sind für mich immer noch
Black Ops 1
Äh, COD 4 und MW2
Ich bin
Bis da sonst nix mehr rangekommen
Wieder klassische Call of Duty Kost
Mit vielen großen Schlachten, aber auch
Mit ein paar spaßigen Schleichabschnitten
Alles natürlich verpackt in die
Serientypischen Schlauchlevel
Die wenig Bewegung spielen
Also MW2
Der Modern Warfare
Reboot, der war schon
Zu äh
Call of Duty war immer
Scripted, aber da hast du schon
Zu wenig gespielt, das war ja quasi nur noch
Fast auf Schienen
Also ne
Das hat mir nicht so gut gefallen
Dafür aber mit vielen
Scriptsequenzen eindrucksvoll inszeniert
Werden und mit einem hohen
Kalkgrad glänzen, gerade die
Innenräume laden durchaus mal dazu ein
Stehen zu bleiben und sich die ganzen
Kleinen Details aus der Nähe anzuschauen
So viele Medaillen Vater
Deine Mutter bestand darauf
Wer kauft Call of Duty für die Story?
Relativ viele Leute, weil sonst würden sie keine Story machen
Zur Schaustellen
Aber auch in den Außenabschnitten kann sich
Vanguard sehen lassen, die Wüstenlandschaft
Von Tobruk sieht dank
Fotogrammetrie-Technik umwerfend aus
Die Luftschlacht von Midway ist
Ein gewaltiges Spektakel
Aber wahrscheinlich typisch Call of Duty
Mäßig, absolut sinnloses
Anspruchsloses
Entweder Quicktime Event
Oder was man eigentlich gar nicht verkacken kann
Ich sag's euch, das ist so ein Ding
Wo du eigentlich nur 2cm
Links und rechts steuern kannst, der Rest passiert
Wahrscheinlich automatisch
Das wird wahrscheinlich wirklich Noob
Scheiß hoch 3 sein
Die Luftschlacht von Midway ist
Ein gewaltiges Spektakel
Und selbst der Gang durch den Flugzeugträger
Ist ein Augenschmaus
Besonders eindrucksvoll sind dabei
Diesmal die Lichtstimmungen
Und allgemein der Einsatz von Beleuchtung
Vanguard ist sicherlich einer der
Ästhetisch interessantesten Serienteile
Und auch der Soundtrack, oder besser gesagt
Der dynamische Score
Sticht gerade in der ersten Spielhälfte
Deutlich hervor
Erste Spielhälfte
Heißt in der Call of Duty Kampagne
Eineinhalb Stunden oder so
Ungefähr ist das die erste Spielhälfte
Wahrscheinlich so 3 Stunden Kampagne
Klingt aber wirklich ganz nett
Der Score
Kann auf eine stringente Inszenierung zu setzen
Statt sich auf die Freiheit
Von Open World Spielen zu verlassen
Wirst du ernsthaft den League Arcane Launch verpassen?
Ja, ich spiel kein LOL
Liebigkeit verlieren
Telefon machst
So ein Mittendrin-Gefühl
Wie Call of Duty Vanguard kann jedenfalls kaum
Ein anderer Shooter bieten
Zumindest wenn dieses Mittendrin bedeutet
Dass man Teil von spektakulären
Actionszenen mit etlichen anderen
Einheiten ist
Und das Ganze am Ende nicht einfach in
Irgendeinem großen Chaos, sondern
Durchaus noch in einer nachvollziehbaren
Darbietung endet
Ich will jetzt kein blindes Loblied auf
Skriptlastige Schlauch-Shooter singen
Aber bei all dem Hass und der grundsätzlichen
Ablehnung, die den Call of Duty Kampagnen
Oft entgegenschlickt, muss auch mal
Gesagt werden, dass es diese Art von
Hollywood-artiger Bombast-Unterhaltung
Abseits von Call of Duty
Eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt
Da hat er nicht unrecht, ja
Alle anderen Mitbewerber haben diese Art
Von Popcorn-Unterhaltung ja längst
Aufgegeben, oder müssen sie aus
Finanziellen Gründen auf einer
Deutlich kleineren Flamme köcheln
Von daher freue ich mich jedes Jahr
Auf eine neue Dosis Call of Duty
Kampagne, aber genau
Da beginnt das Problem
Von Call of Duty Vanguard
Denn auch beim Publisher Activision
Geht man wohl davon aus, dass die
Publikation jedes Jahr super
Verkauft, also kann man
Ja einfach mal das machen, was
Das ist halt
So dieses Call of Duty Ding, das fand ich schon immer
Kacke, wenn sie dann, also ich meine
Die können ja Schlachten und Inszenierungen gut
Aber diese Camps, die wirken
Immer so dermaßen statisch
Und
Ja
So gewollt und nicht gekonnt, du siehst so
Jeder Soldat hat nur zwei Animationen
Es passiert gar nichts, das ist
Das würde, wir sollten die einfach
Weglassen
20 Jahren versucht haben
Und was auch die Call of Duty Serie
Schon mal ausprobiert hat, nämlich
Eine neue Marke zu etablieren
Bei Modern Warfare oder Black
Übrigens, Fun Fact
Weil ich gerade seinen Namen sehe
Hier, ja
Efril Finbroff
Wusstet ihr
Dass man den Tennisspieler Roger Federer
Dass man den, oder Federer, wie spricht man
Aus, Roger Federer
Dass die Hälfte seines Namens
Aus ER besteht
Verlegt euch das mal
Die Hälfte des Namens besteht aus ER
Gut, dass ich das jetzt mal erwähnt habe
Auch die Call of Duty Serie
Schon mal ausprobiert hat
Nämlich eine neue Marke zu etablieren
Bei Modern Warfare
Oder Black Ops hat das innerhalb des Call of Duty
Universums funktioniert
Bei Call of Duty Ghosts ist es in
War 2013
Mit der Idee auf die Nase gefallen
Denn im Unterschied zu Modern Warfare 1
Und Black Ops 1
Die zunächst als Standalone Spiele
Entwickelt wurden
Und auch so funktionierten
Also ein abgeschlossenes Erlebnisboten
Das mit den Fortsetzungen nur ausgebaut wurde
Setzte Ghosts gleich auf ein
Cliffhanger Ende
Und fühlte sich dadurch schon ziemlich unbefriedigend an
Warte mal
War Ghosts das mit Kevin Spacey
Ne, was war das
Ne, das war Advanced Warfare
Ghosts war das
Mit Jon Snow
Oder
Ne
Warte mal
Nein, Infinite Warfare war das mit Jon Snow
Und
Advanced Warfare war das mit Kevin Spacey
Wer war denn der
Typ in Ghosts
Ach Ghosts war mit dem Hund
Genau
Mit dem Hund der Door Preaches machen konnte
Stimmt, genau
Und genau das macht Call of Duty Vanguard jetzt auch
Doch während bei Ghosts
Vor dem Abspann immerhin noch
Eines der spektakulärsten Finale
Der ganzen Serie
Abgefeuert wurde
Das mit einem Kampf im Weltraum begann
Über eine Panzerschlacht in der Wüste reichte
Und schließlich in einer
Magnetschwebebahn endete
Gibt's bei Vanguard am Ende
Nur eine für Call of Duty Verhältnisse
Eher unspektakuläre Standardballerei
Danach heißt es dann
Hey, die wirklich tollen Sachen erzählen wir dann
Im Zombie Modus
Oder in einem Multiplayer Update
Oder in einer möglichen Fortsetzung
Die ihr doch eh alle kaufen werdet, oder?
Das ist dann die hässliche Fratze
Ja, da hat er nicht unrecht
Statt erstmal ein gutes Fundament zu legen
Wurde hier gleich an die Fortsetzungen gedacht
Und dementsprechend
Da sieht man aber auch, dass diese Spiele
Nicht gemacht werden von Leuten
Wobei, das will ich ihnen gar nicht absprechen
Dass vielleicht die Einzelprogrammierer
Und Entwickler daran wirklich da noch
Ihre Liebe reinstecken
Aber dass das
Gesamtding einfach
Massenware
Ohne
Wie soll man sagen?
Ohne Tiefgang
Ist
Das trifft's glaub ich ganz gut
Weil
Die denken sich, hey
Warum sollte ich da noch jemals wieder was dran machen
Wenn's nicht rund ist
Ich mach einfach nächstes Jahr das nächste
Mal
Also
Ist das
Ist das Captain Price im
Zweiten Weltkrieg oder was ist das wenn's fertig ist?
ist.
Das sieht fast aus wie Captain Price,
Alter.
Also auch vom Bart her und sonst
wie. Sieht cinematischer aus.
Aber 30, aber 30 FPS.
Ich meine, die könnten den Scheiß da ohne Probleme
mit 60 FPS rendern. Gut, ich meine,
das Spiel hat jetzt schon wahrscheinlich wieder 150
G oder so. Ja und?
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten die in irgendeiner
Captain Igloo.
Es ist doch jetzt nicht so,
als hätten die irgendwie Zeitbegrenzungen
damit. Quatsch, das könnten die
auch in 60 FPS rendern. Und
Leute, und Leute, und Leute.
Die könnten einfach auch
after, also nicht after,
post-processing den Kram
hochrechnen. Das habe ich auch gemacht
mit Handy-Videos, die ich aufgenommen habe,
bei mir auf dem Rechner. Und das sieht
auch brauchbar aus. Aber
am besten ist natürlich direkt
mit 60 FPS rendern. Und das können die auch
machen.
Ruckelig.
Expansion ist hervorragend. Da könnte man
einen eigenen, kompletten Render-Film draus machen.
Aber zurück zum Thema. Call of Duty Vanguard
erinnert mit seinem Fortsetzung-Folgt-Ansatz
an die ganzen gescheiterten
Franchise-Versuche im Kino in den letzten 20 Jahren.
Von Jumper über
Ich bin Nummer 4 bis zum
Die Mumie-Film mit Tom Cruise, der
eigentlich das Dark Universe hätte
kickstarten sollen. Der was? Was für ein
Universe? Das soll ja jetzt zwar
nicht heißen, dass Vanguard dasselbe
Schicksal erwartet. Verdient hätte
es das Spiel aber, weil es aus derselben
Arroganz heraus entwickelt wurde.
Nämlich aus der Idee heraus, dass man
für eine Serie nicht erstmal mit nem richtig
guten ersten Teil loslegen muss,
sondern einfach gleich auf die
Fortsetzung vertrösten kann.
Jetzt hab ich aber natürlich eingangs gesagt, dass Vanguard
ein solides Blockbuster-Erlebnis
bietet und meine Sorge um das Spiel
größtenteils unbegründet war. Wie passt
das also mit... Weißt du, erstmal
stealthen, aber dann durch die Zäune fahren.
Weil das keinen Krach macht.
Ah ne, die stealthen
gar nicht.
Tatsächlich in diesem letzten Drittel, wenn
klar wird... Das sind so Anzeigen, die
mir bei Call of Duty immer auf den Sack gehen.
F zum Aussteigen drücken.
Wenn das quasi
normal in das Spiel
integriert wäre, dass du
öfters mal in Autos reingehst und
rausgehst, dann wüsstest du, dass du F zum Aussteigen
drücken musst. Aber nachdem das
wahrscheinlich nur einmal vorkommt für diese
Quicktime-Sequenz,
ist das so dumm. F zum
Aussteigen, nicht für Respekt. Jetzt
pressen wir F zum Aussteigen. Und die Antwort liegt
tatsächlich in diesem letzten Drittel, wenn
klar wird, dass da nicht mehr
mehr kommt. Und dass Vanguard
zudem auch noch unter denselben Problemen
wie Cold War leidet.
Cold War fehlte für seine zahlreichen
neuen Ideen und Ansätze, nämlich
vorn und hinten die Zeit. Das Spiel
hätte doppelt oder dreimal so
lang sein müssen, damit sich die Elemente
wirklich hätten gehalten. Das stimmt, das stimmt.
So toll die Neuerungen auch waren.
Und so ist es bei Vanguard
jetzt auch, dass ja fünf
steuerbare Figuren einführen muss
und vieren davon
auch noch spezielle Fähigkeiten gibt.
Team-Anführer Arthur
kann Befehle erteilen, Pilot
Wade kann seine Sinne schärfen
und dann Gegner durch Deckungen
hindurch sehen und so weiter.
Das würde mich mal interessieren, wie sehr
man da seine Sinne schärfen muss, damit man
Gegner durch die Wand zieht.
Habt ihr eine Idee, was man
da, was muss man da so zu sich nehmen,
dass das funktioniert?
Dafür diese Elemente, in denen gerade mal
neun Missionen des Spiels aber kaum
Zeit bleibt, wirken sie eher wie
Genix, die eingebaut wurden.
Ja, dann siehst du vielleicht Leute durch die Wand, die sind aber nicht da.
Feature-List aufzutauchen.
Selbst eine neue Gegnerart, die sich unter
Beschuss im Nebel von Rauchgranaten versteckt,
also auch gameplaytechnisch wirklich mal
eine schöne Neuerung, kommt so selten
zum Einsatz, dass...
Wer kennt's nicht?
Ja, in Berlin die Leute mit dem
Smokegranatengürtel.
... auftreten, wie ein Teaser für ein anderes,
größeres Spiel wirkt.
Das alles wirkt dann zudem auch noch
unbefriedigender als beispielsweise die Kampagne
von Call of Duty World War 2,
die zwar auf solche Besonderheiten
verzichtete, sie dadurch aber
auch nicht zu Schnickschnack
vorkommen ließ.
Oh, und apropos World War 2.
Da gab es in der Singleplayer-Kampagne
ja kein Fadenkreuz. Bei Vanguard ist es
wieder dabei, aber es kann auch nicht abschalten.
Dafür könnt ihr aber die Funktionsweise
des Deckungssystems...
Ach, ich kann mich an die World War 2-Kampagne
erinnern. Die hat mir nicht sonderlich gut gefallen.
... Steuerungselemente vielseitig
anpassen. Nur die Sprachausgabe
lässt sich leider nicht gesondert von den
Untertiteln einstellen. Ihr könnt also
nicht mit englischer Synchro und deutschen
Untertiteln spielen, wobei die deutsche
Vertonung wirklich gelungen ist.
Arthur bringt uns hier raus.
Wie? Weil er dein Kumpel ist?
Naja, nicht immer.
Überhaupt ist die Charakterzeichnung
diesmal ziemlich interessant.
Hey, das ist der Hobbit, oder?
Das ist das erste Call of Duty
im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Also der hat...
Der Inherer der Ringe.
... einen echten Bösewicht, oder genau genommen
sogar zwei davon präsentiert.
Die sind so fiktiv und überzeichnet,
als würden sie direkt aus einem Kinofilm
wie in Glorious Bastards stammen,
wenn sie im mit Hakenkreuzflaggen
zugehängten Berlin ihre Geheimpläne
für das Vierte Reich schmieden.
Und ja, auch die deutsche Version von
Call of Duty Vanguard zeigt Hakenkreuze
und ist auch ansonsten komplett ungeschnitten.
Während die Darstellung von eigentlich
verfassungsfeindlichen NS-Symbolen
ja in Filmen von Indiana
Jones bis Jojo Rabbit über die
Kunstfreiheit ermöglicht...
Das ist doch hundertpro der gleiche Schauspieler.
Oder das Face-Model, sagt man da.
Inzwischen können Publisher und Entwickler
ihre Titel...
Und wenn dann die sogenannte
Sozialadäquanz-Klausel erfüllt ist,
dürfen verfassungsfeindliche Symbole
auch in Spielen auftauchen.
So geschehen unter anderem in den jüngeren
Wolfenstein-Spielen bei Through the Darkest of Times
und jetzt eben auch bei
Call of Duty Vanguard.
Und während die Trennlinie zwischen Gut und Böse,
durch den historischen Hintergrund sowieso
klar gezogen ist und Vanguard daran
natürlich auch nicht rüttelt, nutzt das Spiel
die cineastische Zuspitzung des
ultimativen Bösen in Form der
Nazis sogar noch dazu, um
ein spannendes kleines Katz-und-Maus-Spiel
zwischen den beiden Antagonisten
zu inszenieren. Das hat zwar mit dem
eigentlichen Gameplay dann nichts zu tun,
aber da die Ränder-Zwischensequenzen
einen nicht zu unterschätzenden Teil der rund
fünf Spielstunden einnehmen, würde ich...
Wisst ihr, was man da jetzt direkt erkannt hat?
Dass die Typen
sind Face-Models
und Motion-Captured
und die Sekretärin nicht.
Guckt euch das mal an. Die Sekretärin
ist einfach normal klassisch animiert.
Guckt euch den Unterschied hierzu an.
Guckt, die Sekretärin
ist einfach ganz normal animiert
und genießt.
Und die Typen sind halt...
So viele Toss-Symbole!
Wohl alliierte Propaganda.
Es stecken also wirklich gute Ansätze
in Call of Duty Vanguard, sowohl beim
Gameplay als auch bei der Geschichte.
Umso trauriger also, dass Activision dem Spiel
für seine Ideen nicht genug Platz
gibt und stattdessen
viel zu sehr an das nächste
Call of Duty denkt.
Es ist halt Massenware.
Da kann man leider
nichts mehr wirklich Tiefgreifendes erwarten.
Was doof ist,
aber ist halt leider so.
Oh ne, der ist auch nicht so.
Der hat jetzt noch gefehlt hinten drauf.
So, was gucken wir uns
als nächstes an?
Motorisierte Schublade.
4S Binding.
Cringe Job Postings.
Der Auer ist auch wieder am Start.
Können wir uns angucken.
Oh, das ist witzig gewesen!
Da hab ich die ersten paar Minuten
heute Morgen
auf dem Handy geguckt.
Das ist so fail, Alter!
Meine Güte!
Ich glaub, das müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Alter, was die für eine Scheiße erzählen!
Das ist...
Ich weiß nicht, dass wir Flat-Earther
im Chat haben, die sich jetzt angegriffen fühlen.
Und wenn nicht,
Pech gehabt, ja.
Aber...
Das ist wirklich lustig, was die für einen Stoß erzählen.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Marty Leeds is the excitable numbers guy
who came up with some very odd...
Da sind Dinger drin in diesem Video.
Die erzählen dir zum Beispiel, dass...
Pass mal auf, ich spoiler eine Sache.
Die sagen, dass die Anzahl deiner Finger
ein Beleg dafür ist,
dass die Erde eine Scheibe sein muss.
Sowas kommt da in dem Video.
Es ist wirklich...
Es ist so hardcore abgedreht,
was die Typen erzählen.
Sekunde, die Lautstärke stimmt nicht.
Marty Leeds is the excitable numbers guy
who came up with...
some very odd things.
But then you actually look at the footage
of this eclipse
and you take it into, you know,
whatever, Photoshop or any of these sort of programs
and you look at, you know,
it doesn't matter what you do with the...
You know, you mess with all the levels
and stuff like that
and what you can see is,
there's nothing there.
There's nothing there.
Well, you'll be pleased to hear
that he once made a speech
at the Flat-Earther.
At the Flat-Earther.
One in which I haven't looked at before.
Moment.
Es gibt...
Das habe ich beim ersten Mal
angefangen gucken,
gar nicht...
Es gibt Flat-Earth-Konferenzen?
Sowas wie CCC quasi nur für Flat-Earth?
Oder so?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Na gut, warum nicht?
Es gibt ja genug...
Sowas wie die Games...
Die Games kommen für Flat-Earther, genau.
Hello all of you.
Hallo und willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Flat Earth Friday mit mir, Simon Dand.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr mitgekommen seid.
Bevor wir heute beginnen, ein kurzes Dankeschön an die Sponsoren für heute's Video, 1440.
1440 ist eine kostenlose tägliche Newsletter, die alle Geschichten des Tages ist.
Und absoluten Checks in jedem Artikel, wo wir auf der Flat Earth International-Konferenz mit Marty Leeds anwesend sind.
Auf der Flat Earth International-Konferenz.
Hier geht's.
Oh Gott, ich ahne Schlimmes, ich ahne Schlimmes.
Proof, Proof.
By the way, Leute, soll ich euch mal was richtig mind-blowing zeigen?
Ich hoffe, das geht mit dem Foto.
Wenn es Fish Islands ist, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Soll ich euch mal mind-blowing...
Mal was zeigen, guckt mal.
Wenn ihr einen Screenshot macht von so einem Bild, wo man angeblich sieht, dass die Erde flach ist,
dann macht ihr einen Screenshot, geht in Paint.
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert mit diesem Foto jetzt.
Oder, weißt du, wir gehen nicht in Paint.
Da geht ihr in irgendein Programm, wo man ordentlich Bilder einfügen kann.
So.
Und dann nehmt ihr einfach das Foto, macht das Foto rein.
Und dann schiebt ihr das Foto zusammen.
Und dann seht ihr, fuck, das funktioniert nicht, weil das nicht gerade ist.
Und das ist mir eine Fische.
Jetzt zeige ich euch, wenn wir ein anderes Foto haben.
Weil wenn man, weil wenn man den Kram zusammenschiebt, du kannst, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, das ist, das kann man mathematisch erklären.
Wenn ihr quasi, wenn man hier auf dieser, auf diesem Scale die Krümmung nicht sieht, aber es zusammenschiebt, dann sieht man's.
Wir müssen mal andere Fotos abwarten.
So.
Oh, was?
Was zum.
Okay, jetzt.
Jetzt sind wir schaffen wir von Flat Earths zu Gott.
Alles klar.
The.
Bra cỢle.
Mean.
Flat Earths Meint das, was das Wort sagt.
Die Erde ist Flat.
Was? Was?
Was?
Okay, Proof.
Was sind wir?
Hat er sich manche Leute schon mal angeguckt?
Also, bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher,
ob er sich manche Leute schon mal angeguckt hat.
Meint er wirklich?
Naja, egal.
Okay, das heißt, wir haben nur so perfekte Proportionen.
Was? Oh Gott! Meine Güte!
Es gibt auch welche, die sind fetter als wir.
Ach ja.
Ja, das ist ja auch so.
Das ist ja auch nicht so.
Wenn man sich das anguckt,
man kommt im Leben nicht darauf raus,
dass es flach ist.
Ach ja.
Also sprich, umso öfter man das sagt,
umso wahrer ist es, oder wie?
Ja, genau!
Auffall.
Passt mal auf.
Wie gesagt, es wird noch viel abgedrehter.
Er erzählt euch gleich, dass ihr die flache Erde
anhand eurer Finger beweisen könnt.
Das ist wirklich abgedrehter Schiff.
Jaja.
Ja.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist eine gute Frage, wenn man sagt, dass die Erde flach ist.
Ist der Mond? Da habe ich noch gar nicht dran gedacht.
Aber das wäre eine wirklich gute, eine sinnvolle Frage,
wenn man behauptet, dass die Erde flach ist, ob der Mond auch flach ist.
Was sie dazu sagen würde, das würde mich jetzt wirklich mal interessieren.
Und was mich auch interessieren würde, ist, wie man erklären möchte,
dass wenn die Sonne, wenn man am Meer steht, das ist ja für mich so der,
also das ist für mich so die Sache, wo ich gerne mal von Flat Earthers die Erklärung hören würde,
weil es jeder ausprobieren kann.
Kauft euch eine Drohne mit Kamera, geht ans Meer oder irgendwo, wo flach ist.
Ihr könnt es auch auf dem Salzsee machen oder so, aber Meer ist, glaube ich, für uns besser als Salzsee.
Geht ans Meer, an den Strand, wartet, bis die Sonne untergeht.
Und dann fliegt mit der Drohne einfach mal hoch.
Ihr werdet auf einmal die Sonne wieder sehen.
Ich frage mich, wie man das sinnvoll erklären will, in irgendeiner Art und Weise mit flacher Erde.
Und weil es kann jeder ausprobieren, es kann jeder machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das dann auch Fake News oder so.
Oder, na gut, eines der Lieblingsargumente von Flat Earthers Leuten ist ja,
Perspektive.
Alles, was nicht erklärbar ist, ist Perspektive.
So Perspektive ist eines der Lieblingswörter von Flat Earthers Leuten.
Perspektive.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja.
Was?
Oh nein, die Mondlandung.
Ja gut, die Mondlandung muss ja auch Fake sein, wenn die Erde flach ist.
Logisch, logisch, logisch.
Nein, natürlich.
Obviously, obviously.
Und wir wissen ja, die internationale Raumstation ist ja eigentlich unter Wasser.
Kennt ihr diese Geschichte?
Also, das wird ja auch behauptet, dass die internationale Raumstation des Video-Footage unter Wasser aufgenommen wird.
Und man kann Blasen sehen.
Drumherum.
Also, das wird ja wirklich behauptet.
Das Problem...
Das Problem ist nur, dass jeder Noob mittlerweile sich, und schon mit einer Kamera, mit einer guten Kamera alleine geht das ja schon,
da siehst du die IES rumfliegen, wenn du an die richtige Posi im Himmel guckst.
Und mit dem Teleskop erst recht.
Du kannst das sehen von unten.
Es ist nicht einfach so, dass man das behaupten würde und Fake aufnehmen.
Du kannst das selbst, du kannst selbst gucken und das sehen.
Du kannst das selbst sehen.
Marty's personal incredulity on that fact doesn't mean it didn't happen.
Never gonna touch the sun.
Too damn hot.
Moon's probably too cold.
What are the planets?
I don't know.
Was hat er denn jetzt damit zu tun?
We have no idea what that stuff is there.
Okay.
As far as we know, it's just some lights.
So, how do we have a relationship with that stuff up there?
We don't need a relationship with that stuff up there.
We know a hell of a lot about it.
We know all about the planets.
Mass, their density.
Their atmospheric conditions.
Their constituents.
The works.
Du kannst ja mittlerweile sogar, das ist richtig big brain.
Du kannst ja mittlerweile sogar, wenn du, ich weiß nicht, ob er das in dem Video erzählt,
aber da gibt es zig Videos auf YouTube drüber.
Du kannst ja mittlerweile, wenn du Licht hast, was zum Beispiel durch Planeten durchscheint,
durch die Atmosphäre von anderen Planeten durchscheint,
da kannst du ja anhand des Spektrums von diesem Licht,
oder das kann man sich beispielsweise auch beim Sonnenlicht angucken,
anhand des Spektrums von diesem Licht, kannst du quasi erkennen,
welche Elemente in der Atmosphäre sind.
Das ist richtig big brain, was man mittlerweile alles machen kann.
We know all about stars, their absolute magnitude, their mass, their luminosity,
their temperature, their metallicity.
Now, granted, there's still a lot that we don't know,
but to stand there and say that we know nothing is an absolute insult to our species.
Er weiß halt nix.
How can we say that, yes, I do know that God manifested me from his kingdom above?
Ach ja.
What are the stars, what are the moon, what are the sun? I don't know.
You know what we can do?
Also, man muss sich das mal überlegen.
Er sagt also, dass quasi sinngemäß das, was in der Bibel steht, das ist so,
aber er kann nicht erklären, was es ist, was an dieser Stelle ist, wo eigentlich der Himmel sein müsste.
Oh, das ist so painstampig, Alter.
Track and map the cycles of all of those heavenly bodies.
Ja, dann mach mal.
Indeed we can.
And when tracked and mapped, you can clearly see that our solar system is a heliocentric one.
And this is what countless cultures have been doing, as far as I know, throughout history.
Ähm, die wussten es halt auch noch nicht besser, bis auf ein paar, manche.
Man darf nicht vergessen, die Griechen waren richtig clever.
Ich weiß nicht, welcher Grieche das war.
Die haben ja quasi durch den Sonnenstand an verschiedenen Orten die Größe der Erde errechnet und sowas.
Das war nicht so richtig korrekt, aber die sind schon eigentlich ziemlich,
ziemlich clever.
Ja, das kam schon so ungefähr hin.
Also, nicht wirklich gut, aber kam schon.
Also, ähm, das ist echt, nein, das war nicht Aristoteles, das war irgendeine andere Grieche.
Ähm, es gibt noch mehr Griechen, die clevere Sachen gemacht haben.
Also, die Idee, dass die Erde rund ist, das gibt schon relativ lange.
Und ich meine nur, weil wir bis ins Mittelalter und die Kirche so komisches Zeug erzählt hat,
ähm,
macht's das, macht's das nicht, nicht irgendwie besser.
Und nur weil mal irgendwelche Leute Sonnengötter angebetet haben,
heißt es ja noch lang nicht, dass man das in der heutigen Zeit auch machen muss, wenn man es besser weiß.
Man hat, man versucht, guck mal, das liegt doch so in der Natur der Menschheit.
Man versucht irgendwie halbwegs sinnvoll mit dem, was man weiß, zu erklären, was man denn so beobachtet, was man denn so sieht.
Ja, gut, natürlich, früher ist denen nichts Besseres eingefallen, wie als das Muster Sonnengott,
aber heute wissen wir es halt besser.
Warum sollte man dann sagen, wir vergessen jetzt einfach die Erkenntnisse, ähm, der letzten, äh, 2000 Jahre,
äh, die wir, die wir gesammelt haben und sagen, das ist der Sonnengott wieder.
Das ist doch bescheuert.
Also, er hat im Prinzip, er hat im Prinzip keine Ahnung von nichts, sagt er damit.
Aha.
Was auch immer, was auch immer das heißen soll, was heißt das überhaupt, ich glaub, das sagt er so, was heißt das überhaupt, so, was heißt das überhaupt, dass, dass alles auf ihn manifestet, was möchte er auch uns damit sagen?
You know, when you look at the world in which we've been given, we have like, we have like Roman gods in the sky, and then the days of the week, they're named like, like Norse gods and things like that, right, and then you actually look at the terminology that we use for time, and it's actually all based on Egyptian gods, there's like no question about it.
Hours comes from the Sonnengott, right?
Hours comes from the Sonnengott, Horus.
What?
Ähm, minutes actually comes from the god of fecundity and fertility, ähm, men.
Also, ich hab das Video schon teilweise geguckt, aber, also ich weiß, dass er das jetzt auch gleich sagt, aber das stimmt nicht.
Das ist einfach, das ist einfach Schwachsinn, und man kann es daran erkennen, dass sie garantiert nicht das englische Wort Sunset mit irgendeinem ägyptischen Gott, es gab doch nichts zu ägyptischen Zeiten in irgendeiner Fahrt und was.
Das Wort Sunset, das ist so, das ist so three-head, diese Erklärung, das kann man gar nicht mal beschreiben.
And then when the sun sets, that's based on the Egyptian god Seth.
Nein, das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
First up, the word hour does not originate from the Egyptian god Horus.
It's actually originated from the old French word Hora, which means one twelfth of a day.
Same story with the minute, originated from old French or Latin.
Minute means a very small amount of time.
Okay.
The word set, I believe, has the most definitions of any other word in the Oxford English Dictionary, so good luck making that one stick.
As usual, Marty takes random words and attributes them to absolute rubbish.
Horus rises, Horus is the sun, and then, of course, is Antithesis.
Ich finde das aber, ich finde das aber gut.
Eins muss man sagen, ich bin immer wieder überrascht davon, mit wie viel Überzeugung und quasi so Sicherheit, dass die Leute erzählen,
können, und die sind ja auch selbst davon voll überzeugt, obwohl es Schwachsinn ist.
Also da sieht man, man kann an Schwachsinn glauben und man kann auch diesen Schwachsinn super überzeugend anderen erzählen.
Das macht den Sonnenschein, du weißt, also dieses Ding hat für tausende Jahre gedauert, und es ist irgendwie in unserer eigenen Sprache verbreitet.
Irgendwie? Gute Forschung, Marty.
Du weißt, die Leute sagen, oh, es ist wie der Ägypten, das ist, du weißt, Paganismus oder so etwas.
Du musst dich erinnern, Acts 7, 22.
Oh, jetzt wird, jetzt, okay, okay, jetzt wird die beste, die beste Quelle aller Zeiten für unser Weltbild aller Zeiten zitiert, die Bibel, ja.
Wir wissen ja alle, was da drin steht, das muss wortwörtlich so sein.
Was, was, was, Sekunde, Sekunde, das ist mir doch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Und was?
7, 22, Acts 7, 22, 22, 7, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22, 22.
Okay, jetzt geht's
los. Jetzt geht's
los. Jetzt wird die große
Verschwörung.
7 durch 2 hat sich jetzt Pi.
Ist das Pi? Sekunde, das wollte ich jetzt mal kurz
überprüfen.
Nein.
Das stimmt ja schon ab der
dritten Nachkommastelle nicht mehr.
Der Pi ist 3,1415.
Das stimmt ja schon ab der dritten Nachkommastelle nicht mehr.
Ja.
1415.
Ja, das Komma
lassen wir mal weg. Das Komma verschieben wir.
Aber das stimmt ja hier schon ab dieser Nachkommastelle nicht mehr.
3,1415.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich mir merken kann,
dass das 3,1415 ist, aber
das, nein!
3,18.
Oh Gott, das ist so fail.
Ach, 22. Ah, okay.
Es stimmt trotzdem ab der dritten Nachkommastelle nicht mehr.
Es stimmt trotzdem ab der dritten
Nachkommastelle nicht mehr.
Es ist Blödsinn.
Aber es ist...
Nein, es ist nicht. Es ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr nah an dem Pi,
aber es ist nicht Pi.
Nächster, 7,22.
Es sagt, Moses wurde in all der Wissens der Ägypten gelernt...
Was will... Was genau soll ein Bibelzitat eigentlich, wenn es um den Aufbau unserer Welt,
des Universums und sonst was geht?
Was genau wollen die jetzt eigentlich?
Was will der mit einem Bibelzitat?
...Pies.
Und war mächtig in Worten und Taten. Entschuldigung.
Also, Moses wurde in all der Wissens der Ägypten gelernt.
Also, als Moses, bevor er diesen großen Sinn hatte, hatte,
bevor er diesen großen Sinn-Revelation direkt von Gott hatte...
Also, irgendjemand ist dann zu Moses gegangen und hat ihm gesagt, 7 durch 22 ist Pi, oder?
Oder wie?
Er hat seine Sachen von Ägypten gelernt.
Ja, wir haben vieles von Ägypten gelernt.
Ägypten war eine gut erlernte Zivilisation.
Was ist dein Punkt hier, Marty?
Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon gesehen habt,
aber es ist im Grunde eine Art, dass man Zeit mit den Händen mapen kann.
Also, wenn du deine Hände raussteckst...
Also, wenn du deine Hände raussteckst,
dann kannst du eine Stunde zahlen.
Also, das ist eine Hände-Hand.
Die Hände des Klocks.
Woher denkst du, dass das kommt?
Hä?
Da bin ich jetzt zu dumm für, das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich check's nicht.
Hä?
Was macht man?
Man hält die Hand so mit dem Daumen an die Sonne.
Aber wie soll ich denn um alles in der Welt mit meinem Finger sowas hier machen?
Ich kann doch meinen Finger nicht 90 Grad nach unten machen.
Ach, die Sonne legt ca. 4 Finger breit pro Stunde zurück.
Ah, ah, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Also sprich, ich halte das so an die Sonne, da muss ich erstmal in die Sonne gucken, okay?
Halte das so unter die Sonne, dann mache ich die zweite Hand runter,
dann kann ich quasi ungefähr...
Ah ja, okay, okay, okay.
Excellent, excellent.
Deine Hand.
Nicht aus diesem Beispiel, aber ja,
die Hände auf dem Klopfen sehen aus wie steigende Hände.
Also du legst deinen Daumen runter,
und deine vier Finger da, wenn du sie nach dem Horizont legst,
das ist, weißt du, das ist generell, das ist nicht exakt, aber...
Wo bist du hier gelandet?
Wir gucken uns gerade irgendein Flat Earth Zeug an.
Also wenn du da stehst, du siehst die Sonne und sagst,
oh, die Sonne ist um 6.30 Uhr.
Ich gehe hier, es ist ungefähr 7.30 Uhr.
Alles klar, easy, easy, obvious, obvious.
10.30, 11.30, 12.
Und wie du siehst, sind deine Finger tatsächlich 15-Minuten-Segmente.
Ja, aber, aber inwieweit hat das jetzt irgendwas mit...
ähm...
flacher Erde und...
äh...
Finger und vielleicht, das verstehe ich,
den Zusammenhang verstehe ich nicht so genau.
Don't do it, don't do it, don't do it, don't do it.
Yes, I did it.
I resisted the temptation.
A 15-degree-per-hour drift.
Damn it.
Thanks, Bob.
Now just look at those four fingers.
You have the 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
And these are your bone segments,
called phalanges on your fingers, right?
Oh, here we go.
Well, that's 12 separated into a quadrant.
Three each.
What is that?
That's the zodiac.
Was zum Teufel?
Warum ist es nicht gleich 69, Alter?
Obvious, true.
That's the exact path that the sun travels,
which you're marking with your hand.
Alles klar.
When you look at the Bible,
the Bible actually tells us
Oh nein, schon wieder Bibelzitate.
And this is, I mean,
this is the opening pages of the New Testament,
you know, where John's out there, he's preaching,
saying, repent ye,
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand.
Nein, nein, ich glaube nicht,
dass damit wirklich,
damit bist nicht wirklich die,
ich glaube nicht,
dass damit eigentlich die Hand gemeint,
das heißt so was,
es liegt auf der Hand,
es ist offensichtlich,
es ist unausweichbar
oder irgendwie sowas ist damit gemeint.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass damit wirklich die Hand,
also physisch die Hand gemeint ist.
From that time Jesus began to preach
and say repent,
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand.
At hand?
And as you go preach saying
the kingdom of heaven is at hand.
Hand, wer hat das gedacht?
Where is God's kingdom?
What's up there?
That's where God is, right?
Yeah, but God is above all
and through all,
and in you all.
In me all?
Well, that's what you think,
which is fine,
not true though.
Funny enough,
this is the thing you use
to open the book to read the Bible.
So there's two basic ways
that you can map the moon, right?
And there's,
it's a sidereal lunar month
and a synodic lunar month, okay?
Excellent, excellent.
We're gonna look at both of these numbers,
but a sidereal lunar month
is the length of time it takes
for the moon to return
to a given star in the sky.
And a synodic lunar month
is the length of time
it takes to reach new moons.
So from new moon to new moon,
that period is about 29 and a half days.
Ah, okay, yeah.
And then the sidereal lunar month
is basically the time
it takes about 27.3 days.
He's actually correct on this one,
but I don't think he's gonna be correct
for much longer.
So when we're looking at,
we're looking at integers...
Ey, ey, ey,
er will uns garantiert irgendwas
mit 27,
also so weit hab ich noch nicht geguckt.
Er will uns garantiert
was mit 27,3 jetzt vorrechnen.
Warum 27,3 irgendwie,
äh,
was weiß ich,
irgendwas mit Jesus zu tun hat oder so.
Garantiert irgendwas
in der Richtung kommt jetzt.
Ist es das?
Ist das 28?
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen,
dass das 28 ist.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Allein schon,
weil die Nachkommastellen
unterschiedlich sind
und sich das nicht
auf irgendwas Glattes addiert,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das 28 ist.
Egal.
Also,
also was,
Moment,
was,
was soll ich machen?
Das eine plus das andere
und dann durch 2 oder was?
Oder was,
was,
was will der jetzt von mir?
Plus 29,53.
So.
Und das jetzt durch 2.
Das ist nicht 28.
Das ist 28.
Das ist 28,415.
Na gut,
ich meine,
mit Nachkommastellen
haben wir es an sich eh nicht so.
Mit Nachkommastellen
haben wir es ja gummein dazu,
das ist ja,
das muss ja nicht so genau sein.
Ich habe,
ich habe legit
keine Ahnung.
aber ich wette mit euch,
es hat irgendwas
damit zu tun,
dass die Erde rund ist
dreht. Eins vor Bein.
Have you ever asked yourself that?
Because you're using it for some sort of
proof here, which means you're happy that the difference
exists. The reason for the difference
is directly because
of Earth's orbit around the Sun.
Because we have moved along
our orbit, the Moon needs to
travel just that little bit further
in order to get to the same phase it was
before.
Dear, oh dear.
Da hab ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Debunked by your own PowerPoint.
Twenty-eight is
right on your hands.
Was? Moment.
Eben hatten wir doch noch zwölf
oder so auf meiner Hand. Warum habe ich jetzt
auf einmal 28 auf meiner Hand?
Oh nein,
es geht wieder los.
Es geht wieder los.
You got one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen and fourteen.
Was? Was?
You got fourteen right here.
What's fourteen plus fourteen?
Okay, jetzt sind die Daumen dabei.
Total Coincidence.
Und? Okay, okay, aber
ernsthaft, was genau
hat das Zählen von
Gliedern quasi an meiner Hand
mit der Erde zu tun,
ob die flach ist oder nicht?
Also wie, was ist der
Zusammenhang dazwischen?
Ich meine, ich könnte auch
einfach was, was ich,
ich könnte auch an die Anzahl meiner
Knie zählen, sag, oh, ich hab zwei Knie
und an mir raussuchen,
alles mit zwei.
28-Day-Cycle
ist right on your hands.
Zusammenwursten, wenn du nur lang genug
das rumrechnest und rumschiebst.
But it's not just
your hands.
Doch, hat er doch eben gesagt,
hat er doch eben gesagt, es ist at hand.
Alter.
Oh nein, an den Füßen auch noch.
You got fourteen here, right?
Same thing on your feet.
Your big toe has two phalanges.
Wir haben an den Füßen die gleiche Anzahl wie an den Händen.
Wie kann denn das nur sein?
And your other, your little piggies there,
they each got three.
So that makes 28 down here
and 28 up here.
Okay, aber das sind dann 56 zusammen.
Was ist jetzt mit 56?
All based on self.
Und eins plus eins.
Daher.
Was?
Was will der Dude von mir?
A wonderful nod to evolution there.
So, that is a mathematical template
that has been given to you
for you to really study yourself
and realize that you are an image of God.
Because we have the same number of phalanges
in our feet as we do our feet.
Really?
Now, 28 is actually the seventh triangular number.
Now, what does that mean?
It means that if you add
one, two, three, four, five, six, seven together,
you get 28.
Okay.
Und weiter?
Oh nein!
Es geht wieder los!
Jetzt sind wir bei 180!
Jetzt kommen wir bei 180!
Fuck!
Okay, jetzt kommt Big Brain Muffs, Alter.
If you multiply those numbers,
so one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
you multiply through them,
you get the number 5040.
If you multiply one, two, three, seven, five, thousand, forty,
adding one, two, three, seven, twenty, eight,
five thousand forty divided by twenty-eight is what?
180.
Oh mein Gott, 180!
Leute, die Welt erscheint mir grad in komplett anderem Licht.
180, die Hälfte von einem 360-No-Scope.
So, that's 180.
180.
Ein halber Kreis.
That's what you experience every single day when you look at the sun.
Ein halber Kreis. Ein halber Kreis.
Oh Gott!
Well, actually, that rarely ever happens.
Here in the UK, we get it twice a year.
That's why you can turn your head about 180 degrees.
Hey, hey, es gibt genug Leute, die können ihren Kopf
bestimmt nicht 180 Grad drehen mehr.
Triangle. That's all found in the number seven.
Ach du Scheiße!
Think about that, Marty.
And then you wonder why God did his work
in seven, six days and rested on that side.
These are mathematical
Oh Mann!
Da fällt mir echt nix mehr zu ein.
Look at all the ways that we experience seven in our world.
Seven colors of the rainbow.
Hey, guck mal, Leute.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ich kann zu jeder x-beliebigen Zahl
viele Dinge raussuchen, die damit irgendwie was zu tun haben.
Und dann danach einfach die Sachen, die passen,
nehmen und in ein Video packen.
Das.. das..
Es ist absolut unschlüssig,
was der Zusammenhang
zwischen all'n diesem Grad ist.
Und geschweige denn,
was das alles mit flacher Erde zu tun hat.
Ach ja..
Wenn ich dünnsches hab', muss ich auch siebenmal kacken am Tag.
Genau, wo ist das Problem?
Alter, was ein Schwachsinn.
Also heute haben wir gelernt,
heute haben wir gelernt,
dass 22.07 fast Pi ist.
Was ist das hier?
Was sehe ich da?
Warum ist das eine Musikgruppe?
Das kann ich nicht aufmachen, weil Toss.
Okay, K-Pop-Kram, alles klar.
Das ist der Beweis, genau.
Guck mal, das...
Was wollen die von mir?
3,14159.
Ach, kein Schimmer.
Was will Google von mir?
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Heute haben wir wirklich unseren Horizont erweitert,
kann man so sagen.
Also ich kann 3,14159, glaube.
Mehr kann ich nicht.
Reicht aber auch in der Regel.
So was.
Was empfiehlt uns?
Wenn YouTube noch schön ist.
Ja, ByteStrikes copy-pasten kann ich auch.
Mist, wir hatten eigentlich,
wir hatten keine guten Bilder von,
von FlatEarth-Bildern.
Jetzt kann ich euch gar nicht diesen Trick
mit dem Bild zusammenschieben zeigen.
Na gut, gucken wir mal.
So verändert sich Battlefield 2042 bis zum Release.
Ja, mal abwarten.
Tja, YouTube, erzähl.
Was haben wir hier?
Personalmangel meets Corona.
Naja, damit hätte ja, damit hätte ja auch niemand rechnen können,
dass zu wenig Personal im Gesundheitssystem schlecht ist.
Da, da hätte man nicht drauf kommen können.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht möglich.
Das ist komplett, äh...
28.
180.
Und sonst was.
Wir sind, wir gucken uns das Video jetzt nicht an.
Ich hoffe nur, die haben Fotos drinne davon.
Ich will euch diesen, ich will euch mal diesen Trick zeigen.
Mit dem, mit, mit, mit dem, mit dem Editor.
Hier, wir brauchen, wir brauchen irgendein FlatEarth-Foto.
Flat, hier.
Nee, das ist auch Mist.
Ich brauche, ich brauche ein FlatEarth-Foto.
Richtig, so ein richtig typisches FlatEarth-Foto brauche ich.
Und dann...
Das darf vielleicht...
Nee, ist leider nichts drin.
Ah, egal, dann lassen wir es.
Gut, also was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Absolute Cringe-Worth-Jobs.
Ja, das ist in Engl...
Das ist, das ist dumm.
Das ist, äh, USA.
USA, da sind die Jobs, äh...
Einmal sind noch cringiger als bei uns.
Mir hat übrigens gestern einer die, die beste, das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken, Leute.
Mir hat gestern per Mail einer die beste Job, äh, Beschreibung aller Zeiten geschickt.
Das muss ich unbedingt ins nächste Video mit reinpacken.
Pass mal auf, beste, beste.
Also, das toppt wirklich fast alles, was ich bisher mir angeguckt habe in, ähm, Stellenbeschreibung.
Guck mal.
So.
Leiter, Leiterin...
Leiterin IT und Innovation.
Der, der Anfang ist langweilig.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Das müssen wir uns nicht durchlesen.
Aber passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Ihre Aufgaben.
Jetzt kommt's.
Ich muss das so der Reihe nach revealen, weil sonst, sonst ist es nicht lustig.
Also, geht erstmal...
Die erzählen dir hier erstmal, dass du irgendwelche Management...
Du bist Leiter IT und machst irgendwelche Management-Geschichten.
Das erste, was sie dir hier erzählen, ist Remote Support aller IT-Systeme, Computernetzwerke und Telefonsysteme.
Das ist im Prinzip einfach alles.
Hups.
Einfach alles, was es gibt.
Das nächste ist, darüber hinaus sind sie für die Informationssicherheit, Fragen, Produkte, Dienstleistungen, Vereinzelte Benutzerschulungen,
Netzwerkerweiterung, Hardware- und Software-Support.
Du machst das auch noch.
Kommunikation und Koordination der Vertragspartner und IT-Dienstleister machst du auch noch.
Verwaltung der bestehenden IT-Systeminfrastruktur.
Hardware.
Software.
Softwarelizenzen.
Wartungsverträge.
Weiterentwicklung der Softwarestruktur.
Also du programmierst und auch noch weiter.
Controlling der IT-Kosten.
Weißt du auch noch?
Verantwortlich für das reibungslose Funktionen.
Der Anbieter von Guest-Internet, Property-Management, PMS, Point-Sale, POS, IPTV, Telefonsystemen und anderen Softwareanbietern.
Fähigkeit zur Ursachenanalyse und Fehlerbehebung.
Software.
Und Hardware.
Und Hardware-Problem.
Verantwortlich für die Überwachung von Netzwerkkonferenz-Servern, Workstations, Netzwerkausrüstung, Telefonanlagen, E-Mail-Konten sowie Unterstützung der zugrundliegenden Server-Desktop-Infrastruktur.
Sollte in der Lage sein, Ursachanalyse für ein Problem durchzuführen.
Pass auf, es wird noch besser.
Es wird noch besser.
Kenntnisse der Netzwerk-Infrastruktur.
Einschließlich kann 5-6-Verkabelung.
WLAN, Netzwerkswitche, WAN-LAN, Domain-Controller, Active Directory, Firewall und VPN.
Vorbereitung und Durchführung von vorbeugenden Wartungsplänen für die gesamte IT-Hardware und Software.
Führung bei der Festlegung des Projektumfangs, der technischen Strategie, der Kosten, des Budgets und den Anforderungen an die personelle Unterstützung.
Ausarbeitung von Richtlinien und Verfahren für die IT.
Verwaltung des Disaster-Recovery-Prozesses und sicherstellen regelmäßiger Backup.
Es wird noch besser, Leute.
Gleich kommt noch der Hammer.
Aktualisierung der Richtlinien und Verfahren in Bezug auf PC.
Was auch immer das ist.
Jetzt kommt der Hammer.
Verantwortung für Datensicherheit und Cyber.
Du bist auch noch Security-Experte.
Datensicherheit und Cyber-Security.
Falls das noch nicht reicht.
Sie müssen sich außerdem über die neuesten Hotel-Technologien und Software-Risiken auf dem Laufenden halten.
Sie müssen in der Lage sein, andere von der Geschäftsleitung zugewiesene IT- oder systembezogene Aufgaben zu erbilden.
Was ist denn das für ein bescheuerter Satz?
Woher soll ich das denn wissen?
Wenn die sich nächstes...
Wisst ihr, das ist eine Wildcard.
Das ist eine Wildcard für alles, der letzte Satz.
Das ist eine Wildcard komplett für alles.
Sie müssen in der Lage sein, alles zu machen, was wir ihnen sagen.
Das ist wirklich der absolute Wahnsinn.
Leider sagen sie nicht, was sie bezahlen.
Und nicht mal grob.
Aber wir bieten es auch vollkommen an der Realität vorbei.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten und Vertrauenszeiten.
Das sind die einzigen Vorteile, die sie haben.
Das hier ist kein wirklicher Vorteil.
Das ist irgendwie so eines der Sätze, die sie hinschmeißen.
Das ist kein Vorteil für dich.
Weiterentwicklungsmöglichkeiten durch die maßgebliche Leitung.
Das ist auch kein wirkliches Wir-Bieten.
Das ist einfach ein Teil, wie sie sich sehen.
Und das auch nicht.
Also im Prinzip haben die keine Vorteile.
Neugierig auf das Gehalt anzeigen.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist G-Bait.
Das sind mehrere Abtei...
Genau, du hast recht.
Das sind nicht nur mehrere Stellen in einer Person.
Das sind jetzt diesmal mehrere Abteilungen in einer Person.
Das solltest du nicht bewerben.
Und im Vorstellungsgesicht KQ machen.
Bitte mach...
Man sieht das Gehalt nicht.
Das ist einfach nur komplettes G-Bait.
Ich hatte mal einen Account gemacht, um mich dann diese Gehaltsumfrage zu machen.
Am Ende kam nichts raus.
Das war komplettes G-Bait.
Ich meine, wir können das mal machen.
Aber das funktioniert glaube ich nicht.
10-Minute-Mail.
Passwort.
Was ich?
Irgendwas werde ich eh nie wieder verwenden.
Anhand was errechnet sich das?
Ich meine das Gehalt.
Das Gehalt ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Aber nicht...
Aber nicht für das hier.
An sich ist das Gehalt durchaus okay.
Aber es ist halt die Frage...
Also hat das überhaupt was mit dieser...
Mit dieser Stelle zu tun?
Und...
Nicht für das hier, ja?
Das war Brutto.
Ja klar, es ist immer Brutto.
Das Gehalt ist schon für den IT-Job durchaus in Ordnung.
Aber halt nicht für das hier.
Aber das hat mit diesem Job gar nichts zu tun.
Das ist...
Gehaltsspanne geschätzt.
Das hat mit der Realität nichts zu tun.
Bewerbung starten.
Wie geht denn das jetzt?
Okay.
Ich habe kein...
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Lebenslauf erstellen.
Oho.
Vorgefertigt der Lebenslauf.
Jawoll.
Farbe ändern.
Kappa Pride.
Nee.
Jawoll.
Weiter.
Äh.
Vorschau.
Ah ja.
Excellent.
Ja, schwachsinnig.
Schwachsinnig.
Also, wer sich das ausgedacht hat,
ist auch nicht.
Ich meine, ich müsste mich wirklich ohne Scheiß
mal bei sowas bewerben.
Nur mit Fake-Namen.
Just for fun.
Und dann sagen Keku,
CD Projekt Red,
Tweet.
Was tweeten sie denn?
Zeig her.
Was tweeten sie?
Wir are currently searching for professional oriented
and open my Scrum Master Agile Coach.
Ja.
In Poland.
The biggest Game Dev Agile Transformation in Poland.
Alles klar.
Alter, sind die agil.
Die brauchen einen Crunch Master.
Stimmt.
Das ist für die, glaube ich, wichtiger als den Scrum Master.
Gucken wir uns jetzt an.
YouTube, du hast nochmal die Chance, uns was zu empfehlen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Oh, es ist jetzt 11.48 Uhr.
Ich kann auch gar keinen Hunger haben.
Wobei, man kann immer, immer Hunger haben.
Wir bekommen nur noch
Battlefield-Zeug
empfohlen.
Never play the German version of a video game.
Ah, da spielt
die Mission,
die MW2-Mission, wo du
in der deutschen Version nicht schießen darfst.
Du Ham.
Ja, das war nur in der deutschen
Version so.
Aber das hat sich glücklicherweise
gebessert.
Battlefield Top Place of the Month.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt nochmal.
Oh ne, das ist so ein super gehypter Typ.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Das ist so ein super...
Oh ne, das halte ich...
Ich halte so Let's Play-Typen nicht aus, die rumschreien.
Ach ne, das ist Battlefield-Fans.
Äh, äh, äh, nicht Battlefield-Fans.
Dings hier, ähm...
Das sind doch die Stimmen von...
Davon, oder?
Äh, nicht Fans,
Friends. Battlefield-Friends.
Nicht Fans.
Allerdings, Alter, wie komme ich auf Fans?
Oh ne, das kann ich nicht haben. Das ist zu viel Reaction.
Das kriege ich... Das halte ich nicht aus.
Das ist... Ich kann so dieses Rumgeschreie
Let's Play-Reacte nicht haben.
Das sagen die Leute jetzt auch gar nicht.
Hey Leute, was geht? Hier ist wieder der Max am Start und heute
spielen wir Funny Game XY und ich darf
auf gar keinen Fall aufhören zu reden, weil wenn ich aufhöre
zu reden, dann schalten die Leute auf.
Hoho, ist das lustig, das Game und ich kann immer noch nicht aufhören
zu reden. Kennt ihr so...
Solche Videos, da kriege ich Anfälle bei.
Die dürfen, die dürfen nie
die Klappe halten, weil die Leute sonst abschalten.
Kennst du ein Add-on für Opera,
das YouTube nicht mehr stoppt? Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass YouTube in Opera stoppt.
Ist einfach anstrengend, ja.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich bin irgendwie...
Weiß ich nicht so...
Nicht die richtige YouTube-Zielgruppe.
Oder war ich noch nie eigentlich, weil...
Ich kann mir
die meisten Videos gar nicht
angucken. Na gut, das ist normal, so viel
verschiedenen Content, wie es da gibt, aber
gerade im Gaming-Bereich, ich finde
die meisten Videos so ultra-anstrengend
zu schauen.
Genauso die ganzen
Funny Games,
die es da gibt, wo ich einfach nur
ultra-schlechte Spiele sehe und
irgendein, der das
spielt und auch nicht lustig
ist, also keine Ahnung, es ist nicht
meins. Du hast aber auch...
Du hast aber auch durchgehend in deinen YouTube-Videos gelabert.
Ich rede durchgehend, weil ich was zu einem Thema sage.
Aber du kannst meine Videos nicht vergleichen mit
irgendeinem super-hyperaktiven
Let's-Player-Dude.
Hol dir wenigstens noch Luft.
Oh, ich habe gerade eine Mail
bekommen von Viktoria.
Sie sucht mich und möchte jetzt über
chatlive.me
mit mir chatten.
Alles klar.
Seems legit.
So, ähm...
The man that thinks koalas...
A CGI. Oh Gott, es gibt
verrückte Leute halt.
Irgendwie gibt es nichts, was ich mir angucken will.
Wir können doch...
Das Video vom Bauer zu übertakten mit dem...
Mit der neuen...
Das gucken wir uns noch an. Oh, ab 24 Minuten.
Okay, da müssen wir ein bisschen vorskippen.
Ja, aua.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen Video.
Jetzt auch endlich zum Launch-Video zum 12.900k.
Ich habe ein paar Details...
Ich skippe mal ein bisschen vor.
...DDR4, DDR4...
Wo wird übertaktet?
Aber passt jetzt.
Alles montiert.
Ist das Hetzner-Sellout?
Das ist Hetzner-Sellout.
...von unserem Partner Hetzner,
die ich auf jeden Fall mit euch teilen möchte.
Ich weiß natürlich, dass die meisten von euch aus Deutschland kommen,
aber Hetzner hat jetzt auch in die USA...
Wait a minute.
Ich hab die vorgestern gefragt,
ob ich ein neues Video nehmen soll
für das Video nächste Woche oder
das alte Videomaterial.
Warum kriegt der Bauer
neues Videomaterial?
Und ich nicht.
Anzeige ist raus.
Wobei, ich glaube, das hat er selbst aufgenommen, oder?
Ich glaube, das hat er selbst aufgenommen.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Natürlich bietet Hetzner auch an dem Standort USA
alle gewohnten Features, wie superschnelle Verfügbarkeit,
unschlagbare Preisleistung ab 3,49 Euro im Monat.
Mehr dazu findet ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
So, das kommt dann einfach von hinten drauf.
Stefan ist übrigens auch wieder am Start.
Mit dem haben wir ja vor kurzem schon mal ein bisschen physisch...
Erstmal schön Zahnpasta drauf.
Wow.
Ja, das muss sein.
Erstmal schön auffüllen.
Ihr seht, wir haben jetzt schon angefangen,
das System runterzukühlen.
Ich habe nur ein bisschen minus 20 Grad
und schauen jetzt mal,
ob das alles so funktioniert.
Dann erstmal Mittagessen.
Erstmal schön Pizza.
Und dann ganz runterkühlen.
Minus 200 und dann geht's ab.
Die, die sich jetzt getriggert gefühlt haben,
natürlich hat es nur minus 196 Grad.
Ja, danke schön.
Nur minus 196 Grad.
Anzap.
Wir starten jetzt einfach mal mit 5,5 Gigahertz,
1,45 Volt.
Anzap, direkt.
Die E-Cores laufen auch nur auf 4.
Die lassen sich generell nicht so krass takten.
Ram, wie gesagt, ist jetzt auch nicht so krass.
Einfach mal checken, ob das soweit alles funktioniert,
weil wenn es jetzt schon crasht,
dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich ein anderes Problem.
Aber es sieht soweit gut aus.
Ich schätze mal, punktetechnisch müsste das so Richtung 12.000 gehen.
Ich finde das krass, wie schnell das geht mittlerweile.
Ich kann mich noch an die alten Cinebench-Dinger erinnern,
wenn ihr die oder Cinebench, wie auch immer das Ding ausspricht,
so oft gemacht.
Da ging dann im Kreis so ein Ding.
Das ist schon wirklich schnell geworden.
Ja, knapp drunter.
Also es variiert ja auch immer so ein bisschen,
je nach Run zu Run.
Also wenn wir das jetzt nochmal auflassen,
ist es vielleicht ein bisschen höher.
Aber jetzt sind wir auf jeden Fall soweit,
dass wir komplett runterkühlen können.
Cinebench, alles klar.
Das Wichtigste ist natürlich der RGB-RAM dabei.
Ohne den würde da nichts funktionieren.
Das ist ja schon mal klar.
Der Dominator Platinium.
Mittlerweile hat Hardware echt super extreme Namen so.
Ich bin ja immer noch,
beste Namen waren immer noch Creative Fatality Headshot,
Killer Fatality Headshot Pro oder sowas.
Das ist halt was Meditatives, oder?
Das müsste eigentlich so sein bei den 12.900 Ks.
Das heißt, wir kühlen jetzt mal noch vollkühlen.
Leitet das Stromflüssigstickstoff?
Ich glaube nicht, aber die decken das ab,
dass es kein Kondenswasser und so gibt.
Also die decken das immer ab,
dass es sich, dass es keinen Kurzschluss gibt.
Ob das was leitet, habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Aber das Kondenswasser, was da dran ist,
das leitet auf jeden Fall.
Und deswegen decken sie das immer ab.
Flüssigstickstoff da drin hält das Ding so kalt wie möglich.
Kann man auch rein theoretisch dann
oder tendenziell dann die besten Werte natürlich erreichen.
Muss auch dazu sagen, das Thermometer ist nicht kalt.
Kalibriert.
Das heißt, es hat eine enorme Abweichung,
wahrscheinlich von 20, 30.
Ist es jetzt schon voll, schon voll?
Wenn es, wenn es 30 Grad falsch ist,
dann ist es ja, dann kann man das ja im Kopf kalibrieren.
Aber das mache ich nicht immer gleich.
Dann hat der Boden halt rein theoretisch so wahrscheinlich
so irgendwas zwischen minus 190, minus 193.
Aber für uns ist es egal.
Wir brauchen es nur als Richtwert, um zu wissen.
Okay, es ist kalt und der Richtwert sagt, es ist kalt.
Full Pod läuft auf jeden Fall.
Es ist immer noch ein Stock Setting.
Ich lasse jetzt mal die Spannung, so wie sie ist.
Bei 1,45 ca.
Gib ihm.
Wir checken jetzt einfach mal, wie groß der Einfluss von der Temperatur ist
und wie hoch wir kommen, wenn wir die Spannung so niedrig lassen.
Weil das ist echt immer sehr, sehr krass, wie viel höher man kommt.
Gib ihm.
Einfach nur durch das Senken der Temperatur.
Ist halt echt krass, guck mal, schon 6,7.
Boah, boah.
Ja gut, ohne Desktop, ohne das, was ist.
Na, mal gucken, ob da das...
6,8 Gigahertz möglich sind.
Nur 1,4 Volt.
Und jetzt schrauben wir mal die Spannung weiter hoch und schauen, ob wir da über 7 Gigahertz erreichen können.
CPU scheint auf jeden Fall mehr Spannung zu wollen.
Also sind wir jetzt wieder bei 7 Gigahertz auf allen Kanten.
Boah.
7,1 nochmal.
Gut, das kann man natürlich jetzt nicht für den täglichen Betrieb irgendwie realistisch da rauslesen, aber schon nice.
1,7 Volt jetzt mittlerweile.
Ist natürlich so, wenn wir das validieren...
Ja, soweit sind wir nicht gekommen, okay.
Naja.
Aber 7,1 haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Wir probieren jetzt nochmal ein bisschen mehr Spannung.
1,75.
Gib ihm, gib ihm.
Wir haben jetzt gerade die 7,1 schon validiert.
Also das passt auf jeden Fall auf allen 8-Kernen.
E-Core ist natürlich auch aktiv, jetzt mal schauen.
Ja, 7,2, war ein bisschen zu viel.
Gefreest.
Wir haben jetzt hier gerade eine relativ interessante und auch komische Situation, ich weiß noch nicht genau, woran es liegt.
Auf jeden Fall, wir haben 6,4 Gigahertz.
Wenn ich jetzt den Cinebench starte, taktet die CPU sich munter runter auf 5,7, obwohl eigentlich alles an Energiespar-Sachen...
...und AVX-Offset und alles ist komplett aus.
Dementsprechend ganz komisch, weil wir uns gerade gedacht haben, so ey, warum gehen wir immer weiter hoch?
Was zieht das Ding an Strom?
Ja, das würde mich jetzt auch mal interessieren.
Irgendwie geht die Leistung nicht weiter hoch.
Wir haben jetzt anscheinend eine Feder gefunden.
Ich lasse das jetzt nochmal laufen.
Was war das?
Hab schon gesehen, die Punktzahl war schon mal höher.
Schon truff das Zeug.
Mittlerweile ein bisschen eingeeist, aber läuft immer noch fröhlich vor sich hin.
Das ist, glaube ich, zwei Stunden circa dabei.
Da hat bestimmt sein eigener Dieselgenerator daneben stehen.
Das ist nur nochmal ein Test.
Geht natürlich taktmäßig noch deutlich mehr.
Aber jetzt taktet es zumindest mal nicht mehr runter.
Wir sind jetzt auch bei 13.400.
Und wir übertakten jetzt einfach mit Intel XTU, weil sobald man irgendwas im Turbo V-Core verstellt, dann geht er immer auf 5,7 runter.
Keine Ahnung warum.
Ganz, ganz komisch.
Also gibt es da noch ein bisschen was, was in der Software noch nachgebessert werden muss.
Wir sind jetzt immerhin soweit, dass 6,5 Gigahertz ziemlich stabil läuft.
Der Cache bei der CPU läuft jetzt bei 5,3 und die E-Cores laufen auch auf 5,3.
E-Cores höher zu takten hat irgendwie nichts gebracht.
Das geht schon krass schnell mit 16 Kernen.
Unabhängig von übertaktet oder nicht.
Das flutscht schon richtig.
Ob Cache noch ein bisschen was bringt.
Aber wir sind auf jeden Fall immer stabil bei den 14.300.
Mal schauen, ob 6,6 Gigahertz auch noch drin sind.
Ah, okay.
Da sind wir jetzt so ein bisschen am Limit der CPU.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade noch einen Benchmark machen mit Far Cry 6, weil ich das so ein bisschen...
Startet wahrscheinlich nicht mehr richtig, doch.
Natürlich hat dann Ubisoft sich so gedacht, ey, bei 6,5 Gigahertz, gar kein Problem.
Erstmal Spiel updaten.
Spannend, 1,2 Gigahertz runterladen.
Ich bin echt mal gespannt, wie sich das auf die FPS auswirkt.
Also ich hatte den Test mit 1080p gemacht, genau.
Funktionieren tut es auf jeden Fall.
Ist natürlich irgendwann dann wahrscheinlich auch mal im Grafikkarten-Limit.
Muss ich dann mal zu Hause vergleichen, wie die Werte aussehen.
Lutscht ganz gut.
Das ist das, was ich in der Luft getestet habe.
Mittlerweile fast 18 Uhr.
Das System läuft immer noch dafür, dass wir auch nicht wirklich isoliert haben.
Muss ich sagen, echt krass.
Gerade läuft HWBOT X265 Benchmark.
Also das ist quasi X265 Video Encoding, Decoding.
Und jetzt können wir mal kurz schauen, wie hier die Systemleistungsaufnahme ist.
Jetzt bin ich natürlich komplett durchgecycelt.
Na komm schon.
So.
Ist jetzt gerade der Benchmark durch?
Ja.
Na perfekt.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, das ist ein bisschen wenig, oder?
Ja, so gute 300, 320.
350 Watt Peak vielleicht.
Dafür, dass ja nur die CPU-Unterlast ist.
Ist echt schon ganz ordentlich.
Aber es ist auch gar nicht so viel.
Da sieht man einfach, wie viel die Kälte bringt.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn man jetzt ganz normal mit einer I.O. übertakten würde oder mit einer Custom-Wasserkühlung,
dann würde man den Wert locker übertrumpfen können.
Das ist der Benchmark.
Und Ergebnis 32,33 FPS.
Aktueller Weltrekord.
Zumindest mal zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo diese CPU noch nicht veröffentlicht ist.
28 FPS.
Weltrekord.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt nicht jemand anderes ein krass besseres Ergebnis hat,
das ist mit 6,4 Gigahertz gemacht,
dann wäre das zumindest mal ein neuer Weltrekord.
Schon krass.
Eine Sache probieren wir jetzt noch.
Und zwar, AVX512 ist aktiv, wenn man die E-Cores ausmacht.
Wie genau das funktioniert und wie das zusammenhängt,
das gibt es demnächst in einem extra Video.
Wahrscheinlich morgen, übermorgen oder in den Tagen danach.
Und wir werden jetzt mal den Y-Cruncher machen.
Das ist auch ein Benchmark.
Und der nutzt AVX.
Das könnte natürlich ein bisschen schwierig für die CPU sein,
weil AVX512 eben für die CPU krasse Last bedeutet.
Deswegen filme ich das zur Sicherheit mal mit,
weil das könnte auch sein, dass die CPU sagt, ich bin da mal weg.
Der Y-Cruncher.
Irgendwie hat das was Meditatives, diese Sachen da zuzugucken.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Das war wohl zu viel.
Ja.
Ist bestimmt nur wegen der Kälte.
Okay, die CPU ist noch am Leben.
Okay, scheint noch zu gehen.
Und mit 21 Sekunden, auch das wäre ein neuer Weltrekord.
Krass.
Eine kleine, unscheinbare, aber extrem hilfreiche Sache möchte ich euch noch zeigen.
Und zwar ist das ROG True Voltation Tool.
Was?
Dieses kleine Ding hier.
Und das ist nichts anderes als ein USB-Osteoskop.
Das könnte man natürlich auch einfach über den internen USB-Stecker hier drauf anstecken.
Oh, massive.
Aber so im externen Laptop.
Und am Notebook haben wir dann letztendlich eine ganz einfache Osteoskop-Software.
Ein USB-Osteoskop.
Passiert nicht wirklich was.
Wir sehen hier rechts unten.
Maximumspannung, die er hatte, waren 1,72, Minimum 1,67.
Und durchschnittlich gerade 1,689.
Das sehen wir hier oben.
Das läuft auch.
Da kann man jetzt zum Beispiel einen Trigger...
So, mit dieser beiden...
Okay, also man sieht, man kann das super übertacken bei minus 180 Grad.
Excellent.
Mich würde natürlich mal interessieren, wie das dann realistisch ist, wenn das Ding rauskommt.
Falls man das überhaupt bekommt, ja.
Aktuell ist es ja immer schwierig, CPUs zu bekommen.
Könnte man denn jetzt eigentlich einen kaufen?
Ja, bei Alternate.
Aber ob der lieferbar ist?
Ist der lieferbar?
Auf Lager.
Okay.
Wäre tatsächlich lieferbar.
Aber ist halt ganz schön teuer, ne?
Da braucht man jetzt auch das passende Mainboard für.
Bestimmt auch nicht billig.
Das Schlimme ist, aktuell die Grafikkarte zu bekommen.
Ich hätte ja keine Schmerzen mit das auszugeben, aber...
Ich habe halt keine Lust, 3.000 Euro für eine Grafikkarte da noch auszugeben.
Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Leute, ich habe mega Hunger.
Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was zu essen machen.
Massive...
Pipo-Fett.
Ich habe noch Nudeln von gestern übrig und Lachs von gestern übrig.
Ich glaube, das kann ich einfach zusammenschmeißen.
Und dann mache ich irgendwie ein bisschen...
China-Scharfe-Soße drüber und...
Passt.
Koch-Stream, wenn...
Aber kein Koch-Stream.
Keck, wait!
Kein Koch-Stream.
Der lange Lachs.
Im Koch-Stream leake ich mich bestimmt 50.000 Mal, weil ich mich irgendwo spiegel.
Mattschwarze Töpfe, ja.
Gute Idee.
Du hast ohnehin doch schon deinen Hof gezeigt, ja?
Ja und?
Was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Ich gehe jetzt auf.
Bis denn.
See you.